[Music]
and welcome back here to
round four from the tata steel chess
tournament apologies about that we had
some
internet issues on site but we are all
back now and daniel shall we just
straight uh
jump straight back into the action
definitely let's
let's take a look at where the games are
and um
we can maybe start with the game that i
think we left off on which is the
jordan run forest against magnus carlson
battle one of the sort of definitely one
of the key games of the day
well every game featuring the world
champion is going to be a game of the
day but let's take a look at what
happened
when we left off so we saw that magnus
had
basically traded a lot of the pieces he
taken on a4 and he had set this devilish
trap for jordan if jordan
takes back an a4 i think this move queen
b3 would have been very nasty
targeting that d3 pawn and once that d3
pawn falls
then the d4 pawn is a very dangerous
pass but jordan very
astutely does not take he goes and said
queen d1 trying to take the pawn
with his queen with his queen and after
queen v5
he goes 94 he finally puts his knife on
e4 and instead of rushing to take the
pawn
he makes sure that his pawns are
protected that pawn on a4
is basically a sitting duck so i think
he's trying to take it at his leisure
but magnus rook to be follows attacking
that pawn on b2
now i think that we're very very close
to this game just ending in a draw if
jordan takes on a4
after queen takes b2 queen takes b2 rook
takes b2 of course
magnus is threatening a back rank mate
but my guess is that something like this
is going to happen fiona and uh
notice that white is now forking white
is now forking
the a6 pawn and the d4 pawn and magnus
cannot defend both at the same time
this does seem like something close to a
draw but maybe f5 is a little bit nasty
jordan does have
a couple of things to solve here maybe
g4 is a little bit more precise here
in order to prevent it but i do think
however that this game
will end in a draw i like your
suggestion
of g4 and it actually this game is very
reminiscent
of the one that magnus had yesterday you
know where he has
the tiniest of advantages uh but it's
all down to his opponent just finding at
the most precise way to to get to the
draw
indeed and we saw jordan doing that
against baby in round one he found a
brilliant idea really nothing short of
brilliant in a difficult rook end game
and i think that we we should definitely
expect him to
to find g4 as he plays rook takes 84
quite confidently he's got a lot of time
on his clock as well so not a horrible
result for magnus i mean drawing with
black in general
you know he's often done that kind of
thing you know draw some games with
black wind with white
but um although this is a long
tournament at some point you'll need to
start generating more chances
yeah he will especially i think in this
kind of field it will take a big score
to
to win the tournament and despite magnus
saying in the opening ceremony he would
rather take
ten points and second place rather than
nine points and first
i still don't quite believe that to be
true i think
magnus more than anything wants to wants
to win this tournament
oh yeah you definitely you want to win
the turn i think he wants to get 10
points and win the
tournament i think that that is the
ideal scenario but
we will keep an eye as uh this game
enters what
may seem to be its final stage and we
will update you as the queens
are very likely to get traded off the
board shortly uh let's take a look at
some of the other games
my eye is caught by the game of ali reza
perusa shall we have a look at that one
yeah things are heating up so
interestingly you suggested h5
at some point just before we left it off
and that is what happened then
that pun is no longer no longer alive
it is not and basically we had discussed
that
if aryan takes on h5 that seems
inadvisable on account of
queen h4 attacking the bishop the bishop
cannot move because
queen takes h2 he's checkmate notice the
rook on h8
instead aryan played bishop e3 deploying
his bishop and ali reza goes queen b6
he doesn't wait around on d8 he uses his
queen to pressure that
pawn on b2 which has been newly weakened
by the development of the bishop so
aryan defends it and alireza plays f6
and uh the rest just rips open the
position opens up the center and tries
to get this e5 pawn which is kind of one
of the prides of white's position
out of them now what i one key idea is
that if white plays out four here
notice that that bishop on e3 is
unprotected which means that after f65 f
takes c5
i think black can play knight d takes e5
and if you take the knight then
of course black takes the bishop on e3
that's a key detail which means that
aryan
has to part ways with that e5 pawn and
he's decided to do that
by taking on h5 now pinning the knight
black no longer has these ideas with
queen h4 because the queen is on v6 but
ali reza has
taken on e5 and here we stand very sharp
position fiona lots going on
and uh it just looks like anybody's game
here yeah
well my first question to you is what if
i just recaptured that pawn on e5
hit your queen and try and hold on to
try and hold on to that point for dear
life is there any way
no that's definitely i think very
sensible and one idea that that came to
me as i was
meditating on this position is well if
queen c7 then
definitely i think f4 makes a lot of
sense and
even here i mean i don't think that ali
reza needs to do anything immediately i
think he can just develop
and perhaps castle and get his bishop
out to c5 the thing is
black is down upon but that material
advantage in such a
sharp position isn't really felt there's
another thing to notice here which is
that the long-term
weakness of the h file could give black
this
long-term attack black could develop his
bishop also to e7 and then and then
consider doubling rooks on a chain
so uh i don't think elijah should fall
into the trap of assuming that he has to
attack
fast here but another idea for d65 might
be to go queen to d8
and uh this is probably very dubious but
i thought it might be an interesting
idea to
uh go back to that old idea of getting
the queen to h4 which
i would agree is not kind of as
dangerous as it used to be because here
white can take on g6 and then go knight
f3 and defend h2 but
perhaps getting that bishop is a win a
small win
for black so several things to decide
here i think darion is quite likely to
take on e5 although he can also
prioritize his development with
something like 92.
a final question before we move on uh if
he takes on e5
is bishop c5 another option for black
definitely
no that's that's the first thing that i
was going to uh
suggest and that's definitely a good
catch developing and defending the queen
and after bishop takes c5 i would
imagine
well i mean actually knight takes c5 is
possible as well but queen c5 looks
quite sensible just to keep the d7
knight on on that square to attack e5
and uh you know maybe well the problem
is white can't move the queen you know i
would love to play the move queen to d4
but we can't forget the bishop is
hanging and i really don't want to take
on g6 either so
absolutely fiona i think that's very
much possible in response to dd
yeah a lot of things to consider here
ferrari entirely we will leave him to it
but we'll keep a close eye
close eye on the game i'm sure we check
in with fabiano carrana
sure yeah that's a game we we haven't
checked in on in a while and
21 moves have been played so we
we had checked in when hari krishna had
gone bishop to e3 and this
kind of sharp uh archangel ryan lopez
fabi uh we remind you could not have
taken on e4 because of this move d5 that
would
bring a lot of blacks minor pieces under
fire and win a b so fab he takes on d4
he trades pawns and he goes 97. by the
way very interesting
sorry dania because i i see that we have
the jordan against magnus game so we are
looking at a harry krishna against
fabiano
uh but we have jordan on camera has he
played i think you suggested
they seem to be all of this has happened
yeah all of this has happened queen b2
take stakes now the key move g4 is
stopping
uh f5 and now of course rook b6 magnus
preserving
the uh a pawn rook takes d4 and king of
phase and
this is definitely equal the tiniest of
edges for black
literally the tiniest because black has
the slightly better passport and bishops
are generally better at supervising
fast pawns than our knights but that is
a one darn good night
and it's basically unassailable for the
time being because f5 is impossible
rook g7 comes to mind generally in these
end games rooks belong behind past pawns
so that's one idea
uh but you know that's definitely not
the only one yeah
so for some reason the computer isn't a
huge fan of it but i'm not really sure
why i mean this is such a tempting move
getting the rook behind the passport
making sure that that passer
doesn't go doesn't run all the way to a3
the only thing that i was wondering
about is uh could i have used well
i guess it's passive but could i have
used my my uh
my rook to block your pawn from a4 is
there any way for you
now and now that the rook has gone
behind upon is there any way black can
get the pawn all the way to a3
yeah i mean that's that's certainly an
option to consider i mean i think
magnus's idea in that case yeah
necessarily
immediately just to maybe make you
generally deny on
on that square i'm just trying to
understand yeah
what's wrong uh what's wrong no i think
that's definitely impossible you could
just not move the work at all because
as you say the rook is restraining upon
and not allowing it to move to a4 so
maybe you could have focused instead on
getting the king involved i think that's
certainly would have been a sensible
alternative but rook g6 i think magnus
has
immediately spotted the reason why the
computer didn't like
the move rook c7 and what a tricky move
mr carlson
has just made on the board i actually
completely missed this he's just
attacking g4 and guess what thread is
renewing
the threat of f1 not f6 g5 but the
threat of f5 is now once again
very very strong that would win a pawn
and the problem is that if we play
f3 f5 and we try and defend with knight
f2 there's still bishop of
bishop c5 indeed
and um this might actually be the lesser
evil
for white because what you can try to do
here is use the net as a bargaining tip
right all right you can take my knight
and get the extra pawn but end games
like these
uh you know as the old adage goes all
rocket games are drawn but this one is
definitely drawn because
the king is too passive it's cut off and
the extra pawn is just not going to make
enough
of a difference but i have a feeling
that jordan might have missed this move
so
he still needs to demonstrate quite a
bit of precision yeah
and uh magnus unsurprisingly finding
every single you know every single trick
there is in the position he will find it
and some more work to do here
today for jordan i guess we both agreed
that that the position is still
in drawish waters but gonna have to be
precise
yeah and that is just an incredible
talent game in and game out it's never
easy against magnus uh and it really
just never is
and so far it's not that he's been
unlucky i mean his opponents
uh particularly david anton ariantari
they deserve full credit they defended
like lions
they were just unwilling to yield a a
single inch
and um magnus i think has has really
done his best
he hasn't played badly uh but some of
these lines just haven't gone his way he
just
hasn't manufactured quite enough chances
fiona to really
uh get under his opponent's skin but
maybe this game will signify a change
we'll see
we will keep a close eye on it let's go
back to harry krishna
and fabiano carrana absolutely so
we um join here with fabi taking on
e4 going 97 and really trying to
get to that pawn on e4 with his being
keto bishop and his knight
hari krishna going knight b to d2 once
again the pawn is indirectly defended so
if you take on e4
then i believe that after takes takes
bishop g5
you can notice that the bishop pins the
knight the rook attacks the bishop and
if black cements the bishop of d5 then
among other things
um i think that bishop takes e7 queen
takes e7
and probably not the best but at least
something like this would win the pawn
back with some interest
there is however probably a more
accurate move maybe knight to d2
uh but yeah knight to d2 and once this
bishop collapses that pressure down the
e file will be
way way too strong so fabi refraining
from taking the pawn going
knight g6 uh and hari krishna going d5
they trade bishops that the idea of d5
clearly too
shut this bishop on b7 down and fight b
says no that bishop is not going to be
shut down it's
reopened uh but it it reopens at the
cost of this d6 pawn now becoming
a little bit weak hari krishna dropping
his bishop to c2
and um okay before grabbing space on the
queen side and now fabi going knight h5
so
how should we understand this position i
think there's a couple of things to pay
attention to this movement at h5
i think fabio actually wants to attack
on the king's side i think he wants to
go queen f6
and then he wants to transfer that
knight over to f4 that's a
pretty pretty significant square and
he's going to have incredibly active
pieces look at the pressure that he's
exerting also on the e4 pawn
and that caught on d6 while it it is
weak
i think it's very hard to actually
attack it for white if white can move
his knight let's say
v3 but i don't really see how you pile
up on this one
and i don't see any good prospects for
this knight i think black is slightly
better
fiona i mean at first sight
of course you you would tend to if you
just look at the pawn structures you see
well
white only has two pawn islands black
has three so you tend to just
uh think okay i take the two but the
more i look at the position yeah the the
white pieces are just struggling for
four good squares and all the the black
pieces are swarming in
absolutely they really are and um this i
mean
another problem is that it's it's it's
easy to play this position for black
blacks get all of these
very natural improving moves and that's
a very underestimated factor in my
opinion
uh in certain positions is it's not only
about who's better it's also how easy is
it to play if you look at hari krishna's
position
uh you can totally imagine white
collapsing really really fast but black
is all these between f6 rook c8
you know you can play rook d8 g5 should
be considered
so fabi's position is not only slightly
better but i think easier to play
the one positive for pensawa is that
he's got an hour on his block that is a
lot of time
so he really can invest quite a bit of
time to finding i think the most
accurate defensive moves
one thing that comes to mind is beefing
up the security on the queen on the king
side with this typical maneuver
2g3 that might be one way to throw some
water onto the fire but we will see
i have one question the bishop on b7 for
now okay it's doing a good job looking
down at the pawn on e4
is there any ever uh is there ever any
way we could bring it back to
c8 and i opted upon maybe on h3 in
some in some lines i really like that
idea i mean i think particularly
in the event of the queen being on f6
even in this position bishop ch should
definitely be considered
and um i think that's part of the reason
pensa played rook a3
it's to indirectly defend that night so
that after knight takes h3 check
like let's say the queen moves away if
the rook was not on a3
then this move would be absolutely
devastating because the knight would be
hanging
nonetheless an idea like this always
should be considered i mean
sacrifices along these lines should
never be ruled out so absolutely i think
that's possible
i like fabiano's position um i like
i mean what was it it was kasparov who
said something about the knight on
on f4 or f5 right well there's the knife
knife f4 concept uh but yeah i think a
lot of things have been said about
those knights they've been you know
romanticized and
they're the stuff of legend but for very
good reason the knights on f4 and five
are almost
always incredibly dangerous
for sure and there we see our ten
players
in the tournament don't worry that was
quite the plan but we love these shots
so so yeah we do why not
yeah absolutely why not no they're great
they're great we need to display them
we warned you yesterday yesterday we
weren't the headphone users
should have taken our mornings
that is a great graphic though it's very
professional
and um i know that there have been a
glitch here in there but i can attest
to the fact that the production has been
absolutely top-notch our
team working very very hard behind the
scenes problems do arise as they do
with any complex production but uh i
have to tip my hat
and i would encourage everybody to do
the same this has really
been awesome absolutely i mean they've
been so hard
so hard at work i can testify here on
site they're working from morning to
evening to bring you this
show uh so a big shout out to our
producers working tirelessly
behind the scenes um shall we
move on to the from this one and go
absolutely
yeah can we please go to donchenko
okay sure let's go to and queens have
been traded okay so what happened here
now we looked at the snap 497 and
actually the funny thing is alexander
continuing not to castle
i was really expecting him to castle but
instead he drove that pawn into f5
you can see that that limits the bishop
on c8 now it really can't
ever develop to to e6 but it is a
committal move
right now he can't really open up the
file anymore
and so now it doesn't make as much sense
to castle short one of the uh ideas of
castling short was to put a rook on f1
so the way that the queens are traded
knight d6 queen c6 check
right in the into the teep in amongst
the trees
in queen d7 queens are swapped that
doesn't really diminish the sharpness of
the position it doesn't mean that
the kings are saved and drinking when b3
will limit that knight
not allow it to go to c4 g5 by ruddick
trying to close down the position i
think he is preventing white
from playing the move g5 himself kind of
interesting
and here finally alex hunter castles
long it's kind of ironic that he waits
until the end game to do it but i think
it does make perfect sense
uh ronislav continuing to shut down the
position and look at that exquisite
positional maneuver
by alexander uh basically just uh he has
that pawn in his crosshairs
and one very sensible idea here i think
is to double rooks and continue
to attack that pawn and that might be a
mistake because of d5 so perhaps
you should start here with the move
knight c3 limiting the progress of the
pawn
and then fred double rooks white is
definitely in the driver's seat here no
doubt about it
yeah it very much feels like like a
position where white is playing
4-2 results unless he does anything
too crazy the king side is completely
close and he is the one
with the control in the center and on
the queen side so
i'm sure alexander donchenko will be
happy with how to uh with how the
opening
uh stage played out here yeah he is and
by the way another idea in terms of
preventing d5 because
allowing d5 would just enable all of
black's pieces to come up that is out of
the question
uh the move bishop a5 is is also
possible attacking the knight and
trying to get that knight out of b6
because that knight is one of the key
uh pieces that is preparing the move d5
uh without it
that becomes stronger so several ideas
to consider here knight c3
appears to me to be the most sensible
movie he has just played it
okay yeah c3 uh stopping d5 and then of
course uh he can double books i don't
think i think radoslav will make the
draw here i really don't think that he's
significantly worse i think one thing he
can do is just go king f7
and and say all right i'm going to put
my rook on the 8th yes yes this is
passive
yes this is nasty but i really don't see
how alexander is going to
really make inroads into black's
position i mean he's played a good game
not sure he's going to bring it all the
way home
danya i'm seeing in the chat people are
informing us
an exchange sacrifice has occurred in
the fuji game
so we shall return there wow
okay so things really heating up here
and aryan deciding in this position to
go after that
uh light squared bishop with the move g4
and the whole point is that the bishop
actually doesn't have any squares
because
in the event of bishop takes b1 uh queen
takes b1
follows and that knight on g6 is simply
toast that knight is lost
but alireza had cooked up a very
interesting idea
rook takes h5 sacrificing the exchange
as you said for the bishops he takes h5
and look at white's king
white's king is incredibly exposed and
the second thing is this bishop on f5
finally after a lifetime of insecurity
due to this g4 move
is finally safe it is is retired to a
beach in hawaii it is
safe on f5 and that white king it might
not seem
like a significant weakness right now
because
once again the queen is quite far
removed from the king side but
after something like knight h4 maybe
even knight f4
um black is going to castle and we
discussed this this queen
can re-enter the king side very very
quickly
d8 so this is anybody's game this is
incredibly unclear i love what ali reza
is doing here i really do too and i
think especially over the board when you
see
rook h5 appear i think it's like oh no
did not want that no yeah i think aryan
saw it but but
i think he might have underestimated
some of black's play here but the time
situation
after only 13 moves fiona 40 minutes
barley reza this is going to be another
time
as we see knight of four has indeed been
played now a decision to make for aryan
does he take on f4 does he play d takes
e5
this does not win the knight because ali
roza has among other things
he's a move knight h3 and then he can
deploy his queen via d8 a
and alerts i mean after the positional
masterpiece we saw yesterday today he's
showing us guys
i can still play in tactical aggressive
style too
so showing us the whole spectrum yeah
versatility is the name of the game and
uh at such a young age alireza already
capable of playing
such a wide range of positions and such
a wide range of
openings that is just an unprecedented
versatility the unprecedented skill he
is
just so promising and so fun to watch
yeah
and while we see the the bar actually
here says
a very calm and collected zero zero zero
of course
i very much uh like ali reza's chances i
think from a practical point of view
um i think most of us would prefer
playing with the attack but
especially ali raza no for sure and this
is in exchange is not
a wrong i mean that's not a huge amount
of material
it's very significant but it's not the
sort of thing you do and
you know you have to checkmate your
opponent in a couple of moves so we will
monitor how
this attack unfolds but anything else
that's
catching your eye on anything else
that's been interesting to you maybe we
can go back i feel like we haven't
looked at maxim vashila grav in
a long time i agree
let's take a look at the game so
we had we remind you a martial attack as
mvl deploying his rook to e4
trying to smoke that queen out via h4
david until going back on his own
volition
i think this is still theory that
basically what david antony is doing is
he's trying to launch a
battery by playing bishop f5 and he just
wants to win back the d-pawn
because why not and after knight f3 a
slight change of plans bishop f5 would
meet with knight h4
very nasty little move eliminating the
bishop so now the bishop develops
instead to g4 pinning the queen i think
that's a very good move
very good presence of mind for david and
flexibility
maxime uh urgently gets the bishop out
of g4 he sacrifices upon to do so
and he does play this move knight h4
getting his queen to a trip trying to
you know
rest the initiative from black's hand
strength to get his pieces to the king
side
things heat up here david goes g6 and
queen e2 queen g7 feather ghettoing his
queen
leaving open that up 6-4 potentially for
the knight and after
bishop b3 knight takes e3 queen comes
back to f6
and rookie one leads to the position
currently on the board so david has won
the pawn backfield
and i i i like his position i think
after something like
bishop p7 and rookie eight or did i just
one or something
i think oh queen d4 here oh that's a
cool move that actually wins the piece
oh wow that's such an
easy to miss move yeah it is
forcing the queen train you wouldn't
think it so
yeah suppose g4 by the way is not i for
some reason i thought it was a threat
for a second but but it leaves the
knight on h4 unprotected
so dividend zone has time here to make
an improving move
maybe you want to start with the move
rook 80d8s
um maybe you want to move the king
somewhere to
maybe g7 getting it out of the pin i
kind of like that move as well
just so that there are no tactics
related to that f7 pawn being pinned
how big of an advantage do you think the
bishop pair is here for black
i mean it's it's quite significant
because the position is relatively open
i would argue that you know this not an
h4 isn't as bad as perhaps it may look
it it does
uh open up the possibility for various
tactics in the future that's why
king g7 would be one of my candidate
moves um and what i like about maxine's
position is that he
has tripled on the e file so that's why
i wanted to play bishop d7 at some point
and david definitely has problems with
soccer the eval bar liking black's
position i do as well
from a static point of view but
dynamically speaking i think mbl still
has
a small initiative that needs to be
dealt with i mean it could just be a
case that both player is not happy with
their positions you know maxime
you just mentioned it the word dynamic i
mean maxime
is one of the most dynamic players at
the top
while david may be a bit more slightly
more classical style so yeah i think
both might just be might just be happy
with their respective positions
certainly yeah i i would say that the
truth is somewhere in the middle i think
uh equality is is probably the most
sensible
assessment here dynamic equality as the
bead with an
hour on his clock plenty of time and
that's the perk of playing
a flank such a theoretical opening you
get to make a lot of moves fast and
really accumulate a lot of time
on your clock and that goes for both
players but to beat with an hour on his
clock to ponder
this critical position shall we go back
there's two games i feel we haven't seen
in a while i'll let you choose where to
start the asi panko grandelias as well
as do the
game first we had this very theoretical
grunfeld
where uh we remind you and he's
sacrificing upon to get this
active play for his pieces and queen c7
has indeed been played
bishop d4 rook to e8 you can see that
black is deploying all of his pieces to
active squares now
of knight to g4 of course threatening
checkmate and basically
forcing uh the trade of bishops leaving
white
with this slightly awkward knight on a3
we had mentioned before that
the knight often wants to come into the
game via c4 but currently that square is
covered by
black between here bishop b6 is a
potential threat you're going rook ac-8
he doesn't care if bishop b6 i think
queen takes c3
creates a lot of counter threats in
particular against whites
go down this line actually after bishop
b6 sure
so if you take the rook right it makes
ah white's one in exchange but black
takes the queen and then it's very
important to
take that rook on a1 and after rook
takes a one row takes it technically
material is equal but you can see how
bad white spawn structure is and that
knight on a3 is just horrible this is
just not a good position and if white
tries to capture on e3 first which is
perhaps a little bit more sensible and
at the very least black and recapture
with the bishop
and once again we get a similar type of
position white's pawn structure at the
end of this line
is not ruined but uh the knight is still
very bad and
black controls the defile so black is
definitely calling the shots here
by the way just to address a very quick
question in the chat by hoba jones how
does the tournament format work just
round robin and whoever has the highest
score at the end wins yeah
it's as simple as simple as that
everyone plays 13 rounds there we have
it so 14 players here
single round robin everyone is going to
play
13 rounds nobody's gonna to get
eliminated and whoever
has the the most points in the end wins
indeed actually i'm not
i've been put on the spot by myself i
think in case of a tie we'll have a
play-off but maybe
our producers and confirmed that yeah so
that is confirmed
i would love to i would love to see a
play-off always so exciting
i love playoffs i just love playoffs and
um
i've been present for several of them in
us championships uh
live tension in the room as we talked
about you get nervous on
behalf of the players but that's far in
the future we have so many rounds to
look forward to and that's what i love
about chester
simple format you don't have to read a
pamphlet of rules you just
it's just so intuitive player of the
most point wins one point for win
zero points for a loss uh now we can get
on with the game so
dude i went e5 here to shut down geary's
bishop look at this bishop on decor
that's like
atlas holding the world on its shoulders
i mean it really has to keep
everything protected here queen c6
finally
duda gets to his knight deploys it to c2
and now to b4 so he activates it and
gary goes queen e4
this is the position on the board i feel
like this is going to fizzle out into a
dry i still feel like black's got
super active pieces white does have an
extra pawn white can snag another one
with knight takes a6
but this would be an advisable we notice
rook and the knight on the same diagonal
and does black have a light squared
bishop he certainly does if your queen
takes c3 and bishop d3
that forks uh the rook and and the
knight so this would be an advisable
judah has taken the queen and instead
gone rook f
to e1 i would say that maybe he's got a
slight edge i'm not sure black has
white enough for the pun but i do think
that gary will hold his own here and
mega draw
after rookie one and rook has now left
that dangerous light square on efron
which means
uh well i'm gonna ask you does it mean
you have to go back to b7 and defend
upon an a6
i believe so yeah i mean i i just don't
see like if you go bishop f5
it's not that this would be the end of
the world for black i just don't see a
reason to
to allow this uh particularly because
the bishop on b7 is perfectly
well placed i mean it's it's on the long
diagonal it's it's
well defended and a move has been played
and it is indeed bishop
the one thing i would point out is that
judah can go perhaps rook a to b1 and
try to bother that bishop when he moves
the knight away to b3
but uh you know we could play a5 here
and
we might see something like this knight
to e3 bishop d5
the bishop once again re-centralizes
itself i think that's
a likely course of events here you still
stick with your
your previous uh evaluation that
black is fine but still has to you know
find some very precise uh
very precise moves yeah i mean i think
that's
that's that's accurate i think black has
it's not the sort of
a position where you need to find only
moves but i think geary does first of
all need to be careful not to lose this
fund
and he also needs to be careful to keep
his pieces active i think his
compensation hinges on
his rooks remaining active and the
pressure must be kept on the c3 fund you
can't let white
you know reorganize his pieces and and
consolidate
the advantage it's always dangerous to
be down upon an end game let's make no
mistake
i have another question could it be an
idea for white to play maybe
rook a to d1 and try and
push e6 at some point that's a really
clever idea
i like that a lot rook 881 and uh that
may force black
to play e6 himself but that does create
a weakness on f6 i know that may not
seem significant
but one could imagine a future where
like the knight can
reshuffle its wing to f6 so i i think
that's a very sensible idea
which could uh at least face geary with
with an
annoying decision whether to allow e6 or
play six himself
uh well we're gonna let jan krishna
christoph duda
think about his option and while we do
that we're going to take a quick look at
his portrait which was spin just before
the start
of this event
yeah i'm very happy to play here in bay
games again
it's a very strong tournament i mean it
has always been
and yeah happy to be back yeah my
preparation is a bit
you know like not full but
yeah i have prepared some new openings
and stuff yeah but the most difficult is
actually to
you know to get adjusted again to
playing chess over the board
i think i've played twice in the a-group
in the master's group and
once in the big group it was in back in
2014.
yeah nothing has changed and it's very
you know very nice that
you know despite the pandemia time it's
like almost the same
yeah one needs to be you know fit
because yeah tournaments last so long
especially this one
by ganzi it's 13 rounds a lot of time
yeah and the games are very demanding so
yeah that would be you know in the top
of such tournament one needs to be
mentally strong because you know it's
not for everyone
it's an advantage to be to be fit in
serious stress so
i think everyone does it and maybe
not not so much not so many people talk
about this but
they do for sure yeah actually the cri
you know don't expect anything
i don't i mean set any goals for myself
and just
we enjoy playing here
[Music]
and krishna who is very happy to be back
here in vikanze i mean
i think for every grandmaster you are
always
so happy to get an invite to play here
but that's especially true this year
with so few
tournaments are being played over the
board right now
absolutely this is just such a coveted
tournament
i think you hit the nail on the head you
know it's
rare to play any over the world
tournament and
you know tata steel has that incredibly
prestigious
ring to it and for very very good reason
this is an unparalleled
tournament and it's it's kind of thing
that everybody looks forward to every
single year
indeed and how lucky we are here to be
calling
the shots and taking you through the
action shall we
uh go to the well i see you've opened
essie panker against gwandelius which is
perfect
and a lot of nils grandillo's fans in
the chat actually asking
getting on let's just get the portrait
away and let's see how nils is getting
on
sure i mean he's he's getting on well i
think he's
solved some of his key opening opening
problems
and um essentially let's just
see where we left off so before so queen
d3 was this was this interesting move
and zepenko potentially
uh trying to get his queen to g3 nils
played b5 which is
kind of a very classic night or move
also establishing the stronghold for his
bishop if estepanco had decided to play
f5 now
then bishop c4 would almost certainly
have followed and then d5
can come with great effect and sepango
decided to centralize his knight
neil's kind of ignored it for a time and
then he plays
he takes that f4 knight at five i
mentioned this idea this is uh
one of the most i would say fundamental
night or ideas getting that knight to a
very very strong square
and uh the point is that this queen
maybe assabenco here started to regret
putting the queen on t3 because if he
now shifted to g3 well that's out of the
question
because knight takes c4 would just win
at the very least upon
asepenko had to offload you know dump
some
fuel so to speak knight takes c7 and
that's a win for nils that knight on d5
was very strong
as if ben got to give it away give push
the queen back
and now neil's a very nice move queen b7
activating the queen attacking the pawn
and before now
forcing the knight back and now he just
goes ruxian and puts even more pressure
on white's queen
so you can see that black is definitely
calling the shots he's got
excellently placed pieces andre's really
only advantage is that he's got the two
bishops
but i'm not quite sure fiona that that
is a particularly significant thing here
i
definitely prefer nils's position yeah i
agree with you
um rook c8 while the rook is also being
placed
on the same file as the queen looking
down at the queen
on c2 is black's next idea to to play
b4 and try and chip away at the ponz
absolutely b4 is among the ideas that
black has
this all really depends on how andre
chooses to
play the position you know andre could
also punt and play h3
and kind of see what niels wants to do
and maybe try to meet b4 with c4
although i i mean this doesn't look
safe at all that this pawn is weak and
one just gets the sense if that makes
sense that
something about white's position that's
very flimsy even like knight takes c4
has to be considered in these kinds of
positions
uh there's tactical ideas there's
positional ideas
niels is doing a fantastic job so far
bouncing back after
a definitely a painful defeat yesterday
yeah and i always think it's so
important before the before the rest day
and maybe you can tell us a bit about
your experience is so important before
the rest that you don't want to go into
the rest day
with a loss oh
your results on the day before the rest
day completely defines your rest day
experience and when i played in the
netherlands
whether or not i was going to make a day
trip to amsterdam
uh during the rest day depended entirely
upon one thing and that was whether i
would
at least draw the game before the rest
day amsterdam is such a beautiful city
after a win and
really your your tournament experience
and how and i in my experience the way
that you perceive
the location that the tournament is in
whether you think a city is beautiful
depends in large part not entirely but
in large part
on your results in the tournament and
the most beautiful cities i've ever
visited were those
that were associated with a good
tournament well thankfully we have uh
three rest days here so if they were to
lose today
and ruin their first rest day they still
have two more shots
after that yeah and i mean the bliss of
winning a game and then having a rest
dates ah
you win a game and i don't i don't have
to wake up early tomorrow you just sleep
and you wake up oh i won the game before
that's such a good feeling us andre
fenko trying to prevent niels from
continuing the initiative going bishop
g5 threatening to take on
f6 of course um niels can go knight fd7
and then
sort of perhaps regroup re redeploy that
knight to
b6 or even to c5 that's really not a
problem
and black's position is so soft look at
how every piece is defended by at least
one other piece
that's kind of a big deal because it
really makes it hard for andre
to make any sorts of inroads here fiona
in into black's position
yeah and i think niels is going to be
very very happy here with what he's got
you know
all his pieces as you mentioned are
on active squares and we'll come back
we'll come back to this one but so far
uh looking good for nils wandelius
indeed it is
and uh where when shall we go next
either has been
let me just check there have been a few
developments in a couple of the games
now first of all
if we can quickly update on van forest
against magnus and magnus has succeeded
in getting a position where he can
torture and forest for about 50 more
years
now what's happened here we joined fiona
after this
very devilishly tricky move rook to g6
and jordan kind of yielded i mean he
gave up the pawn
and what he managed to do here he did
win the a6 but
magnus using this over extension
technique
look at this maneuver rook h4 i get over
here all right get back here rook d4 now
it wins the pawn if you go rook d4
immediately
then king e2 would defend the pawn but
look at how he he overextends the king
now this pawn cannot be defended because
a3
is protected by the bishop jordan has to
part ways with the pawn and you get this
three on two
knight against bishop position now and
magnus the torture has begun
this is a draw i mean 100 of draw butt
part
if it were a pure rook ending so if uh
if the bishop and the knight came off
the board i think it would be
fairly straightforward is that fair to
say absolutely yeah
if if you swapped these two pieces maybe
jordan should just reach
and take them off the board all right
i'm announcing a trade
uh it's like you know that would be kind
of funny if like uh
i don't know if you know the game
monopoly yeah uh but
uh you know i don't know how popular it
is in europe but it's like offering a
trade i'll give you
you know give me boardwalk and park
please i'll give you and my brother used
to do though all the time when i was
young
and i would always take the money over
the properties be like i'll give you 500
and i'll give you this this monopoly it
was the worst monopoly she just gave me
boardwalk
you know the most expensive property in
the game uh
but uh in any it would be funny if in
chess you could do that you could just
offer a trade of pieces
just to give me you know give me the
bishop and i'll give you my nights
i would love to i would love to see
magnus's face if you heard and took his
night and just you know went
before the rook was uh before the rook
was on a6 if let's say the bishop was
just dependent
just knight f3 takes bishop on f6
that's amazing yeah it would make for a
good shot for us at least
on camera yeah the knight would would
acquire superpowers indeed and
why and it might be worthwhile some
people might be wondering why
is it that this benefits black well
first let's just another piece on the
board so
just by definition it makes the position
a little bit more complicated but
in addition black does have this
ultimate plan
of basically pushing his his pawns and
uh you might experience a situation let
me just make a couple of random samples
let's say white does nothing
and just allows black to push the pawns
but you will see eventually
first of all the knight has to become
passive and after something like rook b2
if there was no bishop then it wouldn't
be a problem i would just shuffle his
king around
but now you can see that bishop d4 is a
very serious threat and if white loses a
second bond
that's going to be losing so this is
definitely a draw but jordan is going to
have to be on his heels
for a long time as time control already
made look a lot of time though to defend
here
yeah i think he's still facing down a
very unpleasant
a very unpleasant defense here actually
also let's remind everyone uh
even if he holds the unpleasantness
isn't over just yet for the day the
players as soon as they finish their
games today
i will have to undergo a covet test
there will be one test before
every single rest day so unpleasantness
never ends today
it doesn't and uh unfortunate necessity
uh and you know it's it's uh really a
treat
uh we we've said many times the fact
that this over the world tournament is
going on
is an incredible opportunity for the
players and uh
i just wish wish them the absolute best
of health and
and hope that this goes goes by without
a hitch indeed i mean i really think
we're quite
maybe just a word here on site it feels
very safe we're almost like in a small
in a small bubble there's no
no outsiders coming in not only the
players are being tested the whole staff
all of us here in the studio were tested
this morning
they all came back negative so so far so
good that's fantastic no
great to see you know like so so much
care being taken and uh
i think that speaks to the you know
competence incredible competence of the
organizing crew and uh
i know that firsthand knowing some of
these people involved they are
excellent and professional individuals
and you can see the organization of this
tournament always on time
uh great shots of the players and uh
this makes my job
quite easy yes it is indeed a pleasure
to to be a part of this wonderful
tournament
and dania where do you want to go next
well let's take a look so let me see
here well envy okay
mbl against anton something very
interesting has happened so first of all
david has indeed played king g7 which we
had discussed getting the king out of
the pin but now mvl goes g4
so i had mentioned this move almost
jokingly uh
and and i had tossed it away thinking
well this gives up the night
but i think mbl has cooked up a very
interesting idea
and this idea might be is it i think
it's to play
g5 okay so now this exposes the attack
on the queen
once the queen moves away if the queen
moves to h5 i don't think that's black's
fast move but we'll get to that in a
second
mbl goes queen d4 check and he picks off
the bishop on d6 he wins back the bishop
although the eval bar actually doesn't
like that move i'm not sure what it is
that
white can do other than queen d4 check i
mean he is that i might be bishop d
oh that's it it's bishop d1 bishop d1
actually kind of traps the queen forces
black
to give up his bishop in order to secure
the h2 square this leads to some
very very complex uh tactical
possibilities fiona so yeah i mean i'm
an idiot
i'm actually struggling to this is so
complex okay
i think that we have a couple more moves
in the game or no because we're gonna
have to
to slow down yeah this has happened
okay this just happened so let's let's
take a minute
and uh maybe you can talk us through
these lines one more time because
very complicated stuff here yeah so so
how should we break this down well first
of all
it's important to go in order of
priority here
the queen is saying that is an
indisputable fact and that is what black
should start with uh the queen is
hanging
that must be remedy now black has
several ways that he can go about
defending the queen and in general uh
there's i think three ways of defending
against the check and three ways of
defending against an attack you can
move the piece in question you can move
the queen you can take
the piece that is delivering the attack
so in this case you can take the rook
but
that doesn't seem like a very good idea
or you can intercept
the um the attack and that is that third
option
is what players often miss and in this
case the move bishop g4
will have to be considered so queen h5
is the most straightforward way of
defending the queen
and that is the only square to which the
queen can escape if you take a look at
uh the queen it doesn't have any options
but now i believe that bishop d1 will
follow this actually does trap the queen
queen is no more squares and in order to
evacuate the queen
black's only option is to play bishop g4
jettisoning the bishop
but the point is that after bishop takes
g4 if you notice this bishop on d6
it is securing the h2 square so black
can evacuate the queen to h2
this may seem almost winning for black
but if you take a closer look
that queen is essentially stranded on h2
so yes
white's king is very weak yes it's under
attack but at the same time it's a
double-edged
sword that queen could very easily get
trapped so that's one option
and if we go back the other option is to
play bishop to g4 in this position
and now mvl himself with several options
queen d4 check seems to be the most
tempting checking the king and actually
forking both bishops
after king g8 mbl has to decide which
bishop he is to take
um i actually i'm not sure straight off
the top of my head but queen takes d6
does look
quite good because this keeps the g4
bishop pinned which of these two moves
will david
tone play queen h5 seems to be the
easier one to calculate
if you take on d6 there was the g5 pawn
not hanging
well i think the idea is if you take on
d6 and i take on g5
i think i can drop the queen back to g3
and
right and it never ends these
complications never end and now i play
f3 and i think the bishop is actually
lost
uh you can't move the bishop because the
queen is unprotected and pinned
so very complex lines to calculate ford
i mean that's not even the only
possibility for mbl uh he can also of
course take the other bishop
and uh if we go back to the other line
queen h5
the other move that must be calculated
is queen d4 check and you can certainly
take the other bishop
but this i think is easier to deal with
uh because david can just take on g5 and
due to the threat of checkmate he forces
an endgame
where uh david will be up upon it is
true however that white does have
control of the e-files so
some compensation here for maxine
there's a i see a question in the chat
by
uh jenstress he's asking so when the
bishop is on d1
if bishop h2 check uh
king h2 and bishop g4 is an option ooh
well i think
the really cool thing is white can play
king h1 seeking
shelter behind the two bishops what a
cool idea
and and once again the queen is trapped
here you don't have a way to move the
bishops around to deliver a discover
check
uh black is still not entirely lost you
can amazingly play bishop g4
bishop takes your point you can finagle
your way here into an end game with
bishop f4 chuck
now both queens are hanging bishop takes
h5 bishop takes e3
but this is certainly not what black
wants because
after rookie three uh g takes h5 white
is most certainly in the driver's seat
but yeah
bishop h2 check would would definitely
be possible but i'm not sure it's
effective due to this this nice one is a
nice resource
indeed yeah so after king takes h2 just
to show the idea
now bishop g4 check loads up the battery
on the bishop
oh my god but even here can you go king
g3
bishop takes d1 and rook h4 and once
again the queen is trapped once again
black has no choice but to force
an inferior end game with queen f3
everything is captured and white's rooks
are more active with this pawn clamping
down on on
all three of black's king side pawns so
not to shoot this bishop h2 move down i
think it's a very sensible resource
but i do think that white has an
abundance of options against it
yeah i mean we see david anton day on
camera
deep and fought and a couple of people
have
gathered around the board to see to see
what's going on in this
very interesting battle um shall we
leave him to it and come back to this
game in a in a little
while absolutely we shall and uh we will
keep an eye on it
now let's see where else we can go maybe
the donchinko game because there's been
some updates he has won a pawn actually
uh but at quite a bit of cost so what
what radic did here
is we we joined when alexander was
trying to pile up on that d6 pawn and
basically what we predicted king f7
happened rook d2
doubling up the rook so my apologies and
doubling up the rooks
but radislav instead of uh doubling
himself and going for the passive
defense we talked about this he goes
rookie eight and he tries to get counter
play
on the queen side i really like that
idea rook d1 and he just says yeah
take my pawn and now what he does is he
advances the spot to p4
he occupies a lot of space on the queen
side and after this mass trade takes
takes take stakes
notice that the move b takes c3 here
would meet with rook t6 counter
attacking the bishops that would not be
possible
but king e7 and now alexander plays
knight d1 so what is
black's compensation well if you notice
these pawns first of all radoslav could
go a4 and
essentially just start attacking on the
queen set but he doesn't even really
have to fiona
i think that the position is so locked
up that even
if rataslav were to play rook d8 and i'm
not saying that's the best move
but even if they were to trade rooks i
really don't believe
that white's winning chances are all
that significance uh because of the
activity of black spaces and the
weakness
of the pawn on so how would black hole
here and let's admit the works came off
the board after rook v8
and swapping a white would have to at
some point
push make a prawn break on the the queen
side so yeah let's say
c3 and i guess you would just sit
or yeah that's a good question because
well one idea to me would be to transfer
the knight over to c5 and pile up
with everything you've got on that e4
pawn so something like c b a b
another key question b if you if you
let's say bring your king off to
e3 and a move has been played we will
update you in just one second
i don't really see a way to make inroads
for white because that knight on c5 is
fully limiting
it's it's vis-a-vis on on
yeah no sorry i let you finish this uh
this variation i was no were you gonna
ask
if the knights were to be traded here
yeah instead of bringing my king to d2 i
was wondering if i brought the knight to
f2 and then to d3 i would just go an ic5
that would
uh d3 but i agree if you managed to make
it to d3 white can actually win on the
spot because you would win the player
not on time but um knight d1
oh yeah no radislav hasn't made a move
sorry
victor yeah so 91 yeah i for some reason
i don't think we're gonna see
book d8 what so what about the immediate
a4
for black yeah so a4 i suppose
is is very sensible here and
if if i think knight f2 is probably
alexander's idea i mean he still does
want to get the knight to d3
uh rooks or or no rooks and if radislav
takes then after c takes b3 notice that
the rook on d2
is defending the a2 pawn so the battle
will begin to revolve around whether uh
the b4 pawn can be kept
protected yeah but um
before we delve further into the
analysis we have
a short announcement announcement as
we're going to show a tweet
and really the tweets add so much spice
to this tournament fiona don't they
so a tweet from our producer here on
site and we are calling for all of you
out there watching us do get involved in
the twittersphere
um probably not with the same content i
hope
most of you did not have to go through a
negative
test today but congratulations to
bigfoot on your negative result
but use hashtag tata steel jazz to
to get in touch with us and you might
find
uh your tweet on the big screen as well
absolutely and uh great news our
wonderful hard-working
producer bigfoot um water without whom
none of this would be possible he is as
you said uh
together with his amazing team working
tirelessly to make sure this production
runs uh as smoothly as it has
and uh will black's defense run smoothly
here
is the key question for radislav voyager
because he ponders
several defensive options which include
a4 or rook d8
[Laughter]
vic is being really modest to us in
private correspondence i think
we're working with what we're getting
okay shall we smoothly
move on to the next game i seen the chat
people asking for fuji
did we have any uh any moves there
are you saying the game wasn't smooth
enough i mean what do you want me to do
he wants me to win a piece out to the
opening and take the game all the way to
the end
if that's how you play a smooth game
anyways i had to i had to make that
reference
given the word smooth it is one of my
favorite videos i mean i love
maurice um oh yeah we all do it's such a
funny video
no it's just a it's just sort of a
classic and it's a
this is nothing to do with any if it's
just it's just sort of a classic but in
any case
um we have a very interesting
situation here in arientari's game we
remind you
that verusia sacrificing the exchange
with rook takes h5 deploying the knights
f4
and then to h3 so and then playing c5 so
very interesting way of defending
defending the queen fiona i think the
idea of this move
is to open up the c6 square for the
queen why is this square good
because that from c6 it actually has a
direct line of fire
to that king on g2 amazing f4 by atari
queen c6 indeed has been played knight
f3 trying to cover up that diagonal
and of course alireza castling long here
he has to tuck his king away
knight bd2 and we have this position on
the board now the computer seems to
believe that black's attack
is quite devastating here a big time
advantage for black now there's
several ways to go about this i think
the simplest
is to go bishop e7 and and then to go
rook here but i have a feeling that
there is something better in this
position
can i just ask you dania quickly a
question from the chat from roman james
can ariane still win
i mean absolutely i think we should not
put too much faith into
just the computer's evaluation here
because this is not
kind of like an end game for magnus's
game where it's they're playing for two
results they are
absolutely playing for three results
here without a doubt this is a very hard
position to navigate accurately although
ali reza is known for his ability to do
just
that uh but definitely any results is
possible i think
particularly given the time situation 26
minutes for 22 moves
anything could happen here and i say
that without any reservations this next
couple of moves
they are going to be crucial as alireza
apparently has a very
very strong option here which we are
trying to decode
yeah so let's try and see uh why the
computer thing
seems to think that minus two i mean
minus two very close to winning
advantage
what could that move be um
i've been struggling to find i i mean
i've had two main ideas
one of them was to play the move d4 c
takes d4 and we've seen magnus do this
against foruso you basically push up a
pawn
and then you carve out the square in
front of it so knight b6 knight t5
that's one idea although the problem
with this is that it opens up the c
file and uh that has to be dealt with i
mean like rook c1 for example
and that queen then becomes pinned so
i'm not sure that's
the best but you know what is always
possible in these situations
is to interchange the move or play
knight v6 first
and then prepare the move d4 here this
is a little bit less committal
because black doesn't have to play d4 in
the event that white does something
nasty
so maybe knight p6 is a little bit more
precise but
other than that the only other idea that
i came up with
is the move g6 and the idea of g6
is to get this bishop out to h6 and
clearly this is bad but
i thought about attacking the f4 pawn
maybe getting the rook to g8 so what
about
very just a simple move like bishop e7
trying to get the bishop out of the way
and opening
yeah opening the way for the black work
no certainly that's
i mean that i think is is there's
nothing that can this can't be that bad
i mean you get the rook into the game
and i think practically speaking black's
got a great position here
um it's it's easy to fall in love with
the email bar and say well this
isn't the minus two move but i think
alireza shouldn't get
also remember nobody's tapping alireza
on the shoulder and say hey alyssa
i just do you better find the move here
so he might very well play bishop b7 and
i don't think we should judge him too
harshly if
he does yeah i mean as you say this game
all true is all still possible and the
time situation
uh this is one of the games where we're
gonna see some action
coming in thick and fast at some point
let's leave alireza to it for now and
let's go back to the game between
jessepanko and niels grandelius well
thanks continuing to look quite grim now
for andre as he loses a pawn and after
bishop g5
at fd7 or no he actually doesn't but
rather the position opens up and d5 it
actually almost looks like he's down
material because look at how active
black's pieces are and niels uh just an
excellent decision to put that queen on
b7
he couldn't have known entirely that he
would eventually build up a battery
against the g2 pawn
but that's exactly what he's done his
pieces well amazingly placed in the
center
andre's pieces on the other hand kind of
scattered around the board
generally speaking it's a good idea to
have the two bishops in an open position
but there are exceptions to the rule and
i would say that here because the
knights are so nicely centralized
niels is without a doubt he holds a
clear advantage
andre has to play this very very
carefully fiona
to preserve something like a balance
yeah i mean i like black's position my
question to you is
the position looks so nice but how do we
go on about
improving it from here well i think like
first of all you know we have to see
what white does and i think
something like doubling rooks on f1
looks relatively sensible when you wanna
employ all the pieces for the defense
yeah i mean it's definitely not easy
uh because if only you had a third light
squared bishop
to put somewhere on c6 and it's actually
two further
um that would be amazing maybe something
like knight c5 and then knight e4
uh make some sense or at least just
hover on c5 and
and eventually go out to d3 if white
relinquishes control over that square so
i do like knight c5
as one possible idea you can also throw
in flick and h6 there just to make some
luft for the king and
ask the bishop a question uh so a couple
of options here that nils will have to
uh work through but um niels is just
he's playing so well even despite the
lost fiona i really like the way he's
playing
yeah and let's let's remind everyone
that despite the loss he's still part
of the the leader group big group at the
top
five players on two out of three and
while uh
well actually let's wait here's a panko
is about to make a move
and it is indeed rook rook af1
indeed oh rook or is it rook g1
i think it's your g one i i watched it
on camera and i thought yeah
but no he went one step further that's
not a move you make
if you have a good position rook g1
trying to get that pawn on g2 under full
control
and maybe free up the other rook i still
think knight c5 makes a lot of sense
here
um and rook g1 rook f1 are kind of
similar moves i think
andre was just worried about eventually
that pawn falling
should the rook on f2 need to move so we
will see how niels
goes about playing this position but
shall we have a look at uh
niels's portrait he's such an
interesting character yeah absolutely
let's see what
niels had to say ahead of the tournament
i did prepare for the tournament but my
invitation got
was quite late it was on the 23rd or
something like that
of december so last couple of weeks i've
been preparing extensively but before
that
it was sort of general chess training so
i'm hoping it will
it will help as a kid i played in the c
group in 2010 and then i saw the a group
sitting next to us and so on since then
i really wanted to play in the a-group
of course
in general i thought it was not unlikely
let's say before the
challenger last year that one day i
would play in the a-group but i did not
expect it to be this soon
i think the pieces still move in in the
same way as they did before but
no it's it's a matter of of the very
long games and the
concentration required and i mean it's
very different from playing uh you know
40 blitz games online where you can lose
a couple and it doesn't matter like
when you play a classical game for seven
hours and you lose concentration for
five seconds it could mean the
loss of the game most days i will try to
run on the beach or do some exercises
and so on
hoping that the weather allows it of
course which is always a bit unclear
here
i think like when you start to focus on
the next game it's it helps with
dealing with the last year i mean you no
longer think about what happened before
when you
have a new game the tough thing is when
you don't have a new game to look
forward to then it can
stay with you for quite some time but
once you start preparation it's it's all
fine
and despite 2020 having been
such a tough year thankfully the pieces
still move in the same way danya
absolutely and um yeah nils is nils is
awesome i'm a big fan
i'm just a big fan i actually remember
you know he referenced that tournament
in 2010 when he was playing
uh in what was at the time called the c
group here it doesn't exist any longer
now it's just the masters and the
challenges i was actually uh in
university studying in france at the
time and i remember driving up
here to vacancy with a friend for a
weekend
just as a chess fan you know to come and
see come and see the action
and i remember neil's very well playing
in the sea
in the sea group with his uh with his
dreadlocks his um
his infamous infamous dreadlocks wow
2010 that was so long ago i was like 11
this he's so experienced too i mean it's
it's crazy when you think he's still
very young still has
you know the peak of his chest career in
front of him but but so much experience
under his belt playing these high level
tournaments and that really matters i
think that matters more than some people
realize
because you just get a handle on on how
to do things how to prepare
um how to surmount losses how to play
long tournaments and uh particularly
playing
in tara i think really helps subsequent
performances absolutely and let's maybe
just remind people
one more time for those who haven't
heard it yet but
niels one of the the members of team
magnus for his last two
world championship matches and that
experience also i mean it's not like
you join team magnus and that's it like
that will pay off you know for years for
years to come you will be able to use
the
the knowledge you gained there
absolutely that must be such an
incredible experience
to be part of you know the greatest
chess player in history and
in his team which of course is very
extensive
and uh is held to the highest of
standards and you know nils holds
himself to the highest of standards
which makes
perfect sense and uh that has reflected
in his results
this tournament as he nurtures and tries
to expand a big
advantage against andrea cebenko in the
middle game he's gone rookie six
lifting the rook up potentially to g6 or
doubling rooks that's also
a very sensible move uh he's pressuring
white on really all sides of the board
all three sides of the board are
one can think of in black's favor andre
pretty tight
up here but we'll keep monitoring how he
uh
defends in this position absolutely i
saw a question and the chat did
magnus lose magnus certainly didn't lose
he is still playing he's playing for two
results
let's see if he's making any progress
yeah so he's
well lots of shuffling we can just see
i'll just
click the arrow button a couple times
you know what this reminds me of is
almost those bullet games where
you're basically pre-moving and you're
trying to catch your opponent's rook
free move
uh you're hoping you bring me book a5
but of course that's not what they're
doing
um or is it but finally we have king f6
i think that it's really a question of
that the
only possible way that magnus could
really make progress is to play g5 at
some point
and then and then to play h5 g4 now
whether or not this leads to a win
is a moot point i think i just don't see
any other way that he could
trick jordan in this position but maybe
he's trying to
to tire jordan out uh first
and then when he's exacer you know
exhausted
from making all of these defensive moves
at that very moment he plays jupiter
magnus is of course the ultimate master
of sensing his opponent's weakness
actually let me ask you one more
question daniel
so earlier i asked you if we could swap
the the rogue for the bishop
well the the not to work for the bishop
sorry the knight for the bishop and the
work ending would be a draw what about
if the
if the rooks came off would that make
white's defensive task easier or harder
that's a great question i think it would
make it easier
uh and one thing to notice is that in
the middle game
you know these pawns on h3 and f2 you
would look at them and say well they're
weak these pawns are weak
they're isolated in the end game these
pawns are actually one of the greatest
defensive structures that you could have
because they're kind of
you know like bumpers they're stopping
this h3 pawn is stopping
black from playing g4 very easily that's
like the first line of defense
then this f1 is the second line of
defense once black's pawns infiltrate
uh the the fourth rank and they will
suffer some losses due to the h3 pawn
they will suffer even more losses
once they reach the second ring so if
you swap brooks here
uh i think that the knight in the pawn
would combine and basically force black
to trade off all three pawns and when
black has only one pawn remaining of
course
the knight can give itself up for that
pawn so i think
i'm not entirely sure but i think that
that's the right kind of logic to assess
the knight versus bishop end game here
also one final word about descending
before we moved on
i still have you know memories from
commentating here in vikranzo with
your good friend robert has last year
and robert trained me so well that even
here i'm already spotting that word to
come down to it that h-bond
nice it's the wrong color
if we notice the bishop in the pawn
that's a great note that's a great point
and this square what kind of color is it
it's a light colored square bishop is
dark
and so uh that would be a drug great
point shout out to
rover tess okay let's uh let's move on
from uh here
so first of all just a quick news flash
uh in a couple of games so alireza did
indeed
play uh the move knight to b6 here which
we had
discussed kind of eyeing the idea of d4
and knight t5 targo and queenie one and
i think the idea of this move
is to protect the e3 bishop why is that
significant because
after d4 cd knight d5 uh aryan does not
know no longer has to worry about his
bishop being hanging he can redirect his
efforts on defending f4 and
protecting his king so alireza decided
not to hurry
bishop b7 has been played and rook c1
once again aryan continuing to
discourage
ali reza from playing d4 so rookie shade
here seems like a very sensible move
uh that that's one possibility he always
could also try to move his king out of
the way
i know that seems a little bit slow but
i i certainly think that eliza should
try to make sure that he can set himself
up for playing d4 at the right moment so
that's
uh what has happened in in that game it
will be
fascinating to to see the next few moves
here this position
uh is gonna it's just it's going to
explode you know over the next the next
few moves
without a doubt and uh the time
situation is going to
serve as the gasoline because 22 minutes
to 25 minutes that's
nothing absolutely nothing in a position
of
this complexity so we'll keep an eye on
this one
indeed shall we check in maybe with uh
oh well let's go to donchenko where are
correct and the rooks have come off the
board
they have yep rook d8 has been played
he's decided on this move i think
radoslav is determined that this
position is is going to be a draw and
i don't really blame him i think he's
probably right
and just to recap you know what it is
that black has to be careful about
as king e7 is played on the board
white's only way to make progress is to
cut into this
this pawn chain and why can do this in
two ways so i can try to go c3
of course after preparing or white can
try to go a3 and
it makes sense at some point either
before or after knight t3 to play king
b2
and uh i think what rondoslav is
basically saying here is that if he puts
the bishop on b5 for example
after eight takes before a takes before
i think it's just a fortress i mean
knight t3 is actually a very bad idea
black is
uh perhaps winning here uh if he gets
the king to d4 so
i think radislap has done the necessary
calculations and determined
that alexander will not be able to make
progress here and i think that's a very
sensible
belief i agree with you dania
before we move on to the next game maybe
we can very quickly bring up
the standings i see a few people in the
chat
have requested a look um at the
standings here so far so that's after
three rounds
we currently have um
five players in the lead danya yeah we
have a
major situation going on at the top with
two points out of three and i think
after this round
we'll definitely have some decisive
games we'll definitely have some clarity
i think going into the first rest day
and we will indeed um and let's see
let's check in with a couple
more games before we go on a quick break
a quick final break before
we get to the nitty-gritty of this first
time control
indeed and maybe we can i see some
requests in the chat to check into the
duda
geary game uh which reached that end
game and
it's funny you know indeed rookie be one
played and
actually so both of so ricardo won
bishop b7 okay b1 and now geary did play
e6
fiona i think your idea of white going
e6 definitely played a role in that
decision and
i think we talked exactly about the
scenarios duda
trying to exploit the weakness of the f6
for i think he is trying to bring his
knight to e4
but um my inclination is that gary will
just take that knight on e4 and then
gary will maybe try to trade off the
other pair of bishops
still white is up upon and from a purely
principle perspective black shouldn't
trade pieces
when he's down upon but the situation is
different here because black has such
peace activity that maybe trading this
fisher will open up the flood gates
uh jan krischev has not controlled he
has just snapped off the pawn on
six i mean why not but giri i think
we'll take on a2 so this isn't
technically
a second pawn sacrifice i actually
forgot that pawn was saying to be honest
i think 94 in light of that
would not have been a great idea because
of bishop takes a2 i think this is
heading toward a draw so this one
might end peacefully but still a little
bit uh a little bit of defensive
yeah work ahead for anish uh furnished
geary
shall we go maybe to maxim vashi lagrave
and david anton
yeah let's see what decisions were made
in that game and
decisions that i think benefits it's not
entirely clear who so we remind you this
g4 queen h4
g5 and david has gone bishop f4 so he's
finding her third way of intercepting
the
um attack on his queen and again rook f4
would be senseless because if queen
takes g5 maxim going queen takes f4 and
they
trade queens the situation fizzles out
the smoke clears david plants his bishop
on this outpost on f5
maxime activating his rook and david
going c5 so from a i think optically it
looks like white's better
because white does have the more active
pieces but
i do think that this rook on f4 is very
nicely limited by by the bishop on five
it really doesn't
there's no way to dislodge that bishop
there's no pawns with which
to attack it uh david i like this move
c5
uh kind of limiting the pawn on t3 and
once he brings his rook and
rooks into the game with rookie rook d8
i think the position is probably equal
um and and it seems like to me that this
is going to somehow fizzle out into a
a drop which would be of course a very
successful result for david anton
yeah and then we see maximus yeah
like i have the masked masked fighter
yeah he's going to yeah nope you could
see him kind of
hesitating making motions but uh
deciding to think for a little bit
longer and he's actually yeah maxine
from what we've seen from the cameras i
think the only player
who who often he doesn't wear it at the
board
all the time but most of the time let's
remind
everyone it's not compulsory so everyone
has to wear
masks everywhere uh except for
within that playing uh playing area the
players don't have to
don't have to wear the mask yeah that
makes that makes perfect sense and
definitely i'm sure the players are
being as conscientious
as they can as maxime deciding to
take a little bit longer to ponder uh
his next move there's a couple of
options here he can
sneak his bishop into d5 and he can
actually try to
orchestrate the trade of bishops here i
think that does make some sense but it
probably
uh it probably does lead also to to a
drop so
we'll keep an eye on that one we'll keep
an eye on that one dania shall we take
one uh quick break before we get down to
that
that's all i think always the most
thrilling hour before five and six p.m
here
local local time when we get to that
first time concern
absolutely and when we come back uh we
will we'll
check into hari krishna karawana we will
keep an eye on
atari against perusian all of these
scintillating games
that are now as you said fiona reaching
their most interesting stage
we will be back in a tizzy
[Music]
welcome back to round four here at the
tata steel uh jazz tournament and dania
let's go straight back
to the games because it looks like
magnus might have
missed a little something yeah this this
game is going to end in a drop very
shortly
and the reason is that magnus and we
talked about i mean his winning chances
here were not
extensive but they certainly were also
non-zero but here he plays the move
bishop d8
the intention behind this move is
completely understandable he tries to go
uh bishop b6 and rook t2 targeting that
weak f2 pawn but
i think he missed well rook h7 is is
sensible and i think he can still
save that pawn on h6 uh by playing
either h5 or maybe even
king g5 and he continues to torture
white but instead a
move that i simply cannot fathom rook h2
and he simply allows jordan to take the
pawn i mean that is just crazy
and i think what magnus originally
intended maybe something like king g5
but now the move knight f3 check forces
an immediate draw
and that's not even the only move jordan
can also move the rook up
uh because of course white is going to
take the rook and the players can agree
a draw
what else could magnus be intending here
uh maybe the move king to g7
once again after rook takes g6 king h7
looks like white loses
a piece but the move knight f3 comes to
the rescue and forces
the immediate draw magnus missed
something but long story short if jordan
takes the spawn on h6
i believe that that will make a quick
draw there might be maybe king
f7 maybe what uh magnus can maintain
some chances but i highly doubt that
this game will last for
more than a couple more moves and we saw
and we see jordan there
uh i think he is going to take on h6 but
of course he's checking
double checking making sure uh that
he hasn't over overlooked the trick but
we also saw him
give that quick stare you know that
quick look at magnus like
what are you up to like magnus
are you did you miss something yeah and
he definitely did and
yeah there must have been some sort of
neural misfire that occurred with the
rook t2 which is understandable i mean
magnus is human he you know he tortures
people in these kinds of end games so
well but but occasionally he will
take his foot off the gospel and that's
that appears to
to have been what happened here so we
will keep an eye on whether he takes
well
he has just taken we had the close-up
camera there
on uh magnus and magnus immediately goes
king
g7 yeah that's a draw rook g6 and knight
f3 is going to be
we can just keep and keep on this game
because jordan is about to take on g6
and go knight f3
and he just did and then magnus will
play rook takes f2 and offer a draw
and jordan has got to be happy i mean
yes he's playing with the white
pieces but nonetheless i mean any draw
that you can get with magnus
is is just a good result and that really
puts the pressure on magnus he's
basically has to win
every game uh and that's not a practical
you know expectation to have but jordan
holding his own early in this tournament
very solid chess magnus not offering a
draw though he just took
on g6 um so we're going to
wait i think jordan goes okay king g2 i
thought he was just gonna
go and try and oh actually did i find a
losing move
dania 94 was losing
um 94 bishop b6
i think it's still a draw after king e3
but
but barely after king d3 this is barely
barely a draw
king h4 king e5 this is actually kind of
interesting and king g5 h4
so white does draw even after king d4
but jordan
escaping the pin f4 knight yeah okay so
they are going to have bear kings on the
board any second now
and um yeah i just agree and this will
be the first game to
conclude as magnus this move uh rook
rook where was it rook um it was a
little bit earlier
okay rook d2 itself yeah that's the move
bishop d8 was fine
rook d8 was very odd just giving up the
pawn and
jordan counter attacking the rook and
now they will sign
the peace accords any second now with
the kings on the board
you could see actually you could see
there the little smile
of jordan and as you said i mean every
draw against minus
is a good result regardless of of what
color and it's been a very solid
start to the tournament uh for jordan
magnus on the other hand though
is not gonna be a happy camper going
into the first rest day
no he's not in uh definitely he is going
to be knowing magnus
not that i know him that well but he's
definitely going to be kicking himself
for not at least generating more chances
in this end game we we can go back to
that
moment when it appeared that jordan
might have uh
made a serious oversight rook t7
allowing rook tree section all of a
sudden magnus targeting this pawn on g4
jordan is
deciding to give it up and in return to
win back the a6 pawn but this three on
two
is something that can be tortured for a
long time so magnus will be
disappointed in himself but at the same
time only four rounds in magnus with a
plus one score
it could be worse and he is at the very
least not going to be far
from the lead fiona so everything is
still ahead for the world champion
as well well shall we see uh have a look
at the other
four players in the in the current
leaders group and see if someone's going
to
take advantage of magnus's draw to pull
clear maybe starting with
neil squanders thought was doing so well
so the four players we're keeping an eye
on are niels grandelius anishigiri and
then
the remaining two are facing each other
fabiano carrana and
hari krishna i think niels is the
likeliest
to and okay maybe closely followed by
fabi
but i think niels is the likeliest to
win his game because we can see
uh the two demons facing yesterday first
of all a very bad position as niels
continues to accumulate the pressure
and knight um knight on e4 is is going
to be quite devastating or knight g for
all of this coming in
and uh isabel go on top of that in
pretty acute time pressure so
what kind of defensive resources does he
have well i think he can take the knight
i think that that makes some sense and
then perhaps
come out to g3 in order to lend some
further support to this bishop on e2 but
daniels could double rooks
again niels is very easy play here he
has a lot of
healthy moves that he can play to save
some time and
we will keep an eye on andre's defense
here but things look
rather grim for him i have to say yeah
and i mean his task is not being made
easier by the fact that he only has 17
uh
17 minutes here we're only on move 23
and tania that's getting to that
dangerous territory i was talking about
17 minutes for 17 moves at least for me
personally whenever i drop
on the clock lower than the remaining
number of moves that's where
not quite the panic sets in but i think
okay better
better hurry up no definitely you get
that heaviness in your throat and it's
like oh god
am i really because the moment you fade
your face with a complicated
calculational task
and you've got five minutes for it for
seven moves i mean you you just could be
busted i mean there's just no way that
you can solve
all of your problems uh playing only
based on intuition it isn't a blitz game
and particularly if your opponent has a
lot of time so neil's not with a lot of
time but
21 minutes here is a lot better than 17
minutes if you're
in andre esopenko shoes we just had to
move what did
he play 93 okay that makes sense uh
getting the knight involved now he's not
stopping 94.
but i guess 94 well 94 looks very
tempting but i suppose rook f1 is what a
sepenko intends
and niels would not want to part ways
with his bishop
not not that the two knights would not
be able to carry the carry the burden of
the position but i do think the bishop
is kind of the glue piece
that's uh that's keeping a lot of the
pressure going so bishop c6
you're sensitive i know sorry no i was
hallucinating i was so
i was so focused on checkmating on f2
that i thought
knight knight g for but g4 is not just
covered once but twice
yeah but i mean you can try to sneak it
in there
to get to f2 no i mean maybe you could
just
move the knight straight up and bishop
before so he uh
observed sorry to interrupt you but we
just see magnus getting
ready for an interview there i have to
say i'm surprised
um that he's even stopped for an
interview because
i have seen him rush past me plenty of
times
and so i'm very curious to hear what uh
what max
is gonna have to say and here he goes
the the annoying thing for me is that i
feel like i made
some um crucial little mistakes
in each three games that uh right at the
end like
i've um not i've not been able to
put maximum pressure uh right at the end
in any of the games
now having said that i don't think like
i had any objective
winning chances in any of these three
games so in the sense
uh three draws are an absolutely normal
result
um as i said like
i feel like if i'd been um a little bit
more precise in
in in those games that i might have
broken through in
in one of them but overall it also must
be said that my opponents are
are defending well and um
yeah um especially in in those black
games like uh
like john played very
solidly today like um
he didn't really leave any doubt as to
what his
intentions were and fair game that's uh
that's
uh that's his um and and
is it your opening preparation that is
giving you
two little chances in the middle games i
don't know to be honest like
today i try to to play something
unusual but uh i i guess it's in the
nature of
of the game that you can still you can
still be
be solid solid with white like uh
clearly he uh he only needed to make um
you know common sense moves in order to
get a decent position but
nevertheless like at the end if i if i
if i don't blunder then i probably don't
win the game but i
at least get to to torture him for for a
long time which is
at least something okay thank you thank
you
interesting there dania uh what did you
make of
it almost sounded like a little dig at
uh at jordan's
yeah playing so solidly with the white
pieces
no i mean i think he's right i mean i
think it cannot really be disputed the
jordan
initiating a lot of the trades in the
middle game kind of didn't mind a draw
but at the end of the day i mean who can
blame him
and that's just part and parcel of being
the world champion i mean it's not that
anybody
i mean starts from move one and says i
just want to make a draw that's not
really how chess works you can't
announce your intention and then
will a draw into existence it takes
accurate play
at the same time you can also understand
magnus's frustration because
you know he drops a lot of rating with
every draw and uh
it can be tough to try to manufacture
winning chances every single game
against players who are
kind of insisting on on trying to dull
the game down with the white pieces so
you know it's not about assigning blame
nobody did anything wrong
uh we can understand magnus's
frustration as he mentioned lots of
these
small inaccuracies that are a bit
uncharacteristic but i also think magnus
he's respectful toward his opponents he
doesn't seem you know
very angry nor should he be because he's
got a plus one score he's poised
uh probably will not be tied for the
lead since somebody is likely to win
but he will be very very close behind uh
going into the rest day so
no reason to worry for the world
champion i think he's played
solid chess maybe a little bit below par
but uh we have every reason to believe
that he will improve
his play and be a contender for the lead
going forward
speaking about uh someone being likely
to win
great segue uh let's go back to to the
game
that we were just looking at needles
squanders with the black pieces against
jesse panko if
niels can win he will be one of the
leaders
going into the first dress day he could
potentially be joined by
anish kiwi by harry krishna well it's a
lot of ifs actually
i'll stop right there let's first let
the nils
see if he can convert his advantage i
mean i think there's
reason to believe that he will uh
because espen go now with nine minutes
on the block if the transmission of
the time is accurate now neil's going
knight to g6 you can see the mobility of
his pieces and you can also see how
flimsy
andre's minor pieces are if he plays
bishop g3
well then the knight on e3 is very
undefended it sits under the x-ray of
black stroke niels could
increase the dial even further by
doubling on ea
just to show an example of uh one of the
things that could happen you know if
andre moves this rook let's say from
from f2 then bishop takes g2 check would
come in if you take with a rook
then the knight is gone if you take with
a knight well then black takes the
bishop and black is an absolutely
crushing
position here so i wouldn't say that
andre is losing
but it's definitely getting uh hairier
by the move and i mean that that
time situation he's now approaching the
the territory where he only has one
minute
per move and that's another territory
you want to be in
uh especially when you're you know on
the defensive
side of such a difficult position indeed
in bishop g3
is his move i'm kind of expecting niels
to double rooks that's a pretty simple
move and it can
once again uh put the pressure even
further
on andre to figure out a way to stay
alive we will
definitely monitor andre's defensive
efforts but
shall we have a look at ferrucci's game
i mean i think that there have been some
interesting developments there
okay so oh yeah this does not look
good at all for aryan none of these
developments positive so
we remind you that all you guys have
played knight b6 here eyeing the idea of
d4 knight and now alireza very patiently
developing his bishop and boom goes the
dynamite he decided
that this was his best chance to play d4
one very important thing to notice you
might look at this and say well wait a
second isn't he
as i had mentioned aryan was trying to
discourage him by playing rooks you want
to say
please don't play before okay but you'll
get pinned i mean you don't want to play
before no no no no that's it
i'm not listening to you because that
bishop on e7
is defending the pawn on c5 which makes
it essentially impossible
that white will ever take on c5 with the
rook who i can take on c5 with the pawn
but that's absolutely not a big deal
this this ain't about pawns
and all there is very calmly putting his
knight on d5
and taking on f4 crashing through the
gates here this is looking worse and
worse aryan trading off a pair of
knights but now this knight from f4
could go on to d3
and fork uh the queen of the rogue now
it is very important not to fall in love
with material here if you do that
and you might end up relinquishing some
of your key attacking ideas here i think
that knight on f4 is worth its weight in
gold so my intuition is telling me not
to play knight c3
but instead to find a different way to
accumulate the pressure what exactly is
this way
maybe it's a move like bishop e4 putting
pressure on the knight
maybe it's something as calm as rook h8
bringing in the rook
uh neither maybe it's even rook takes d4
that is another tactical idea here
uh because this is impossible either due
to quiche or even elegance made
knight h3 this will not this will not
happen in the game
bishop oh sorry i was thinking of bishop
h3
ah definitely possible that that looks
uh quite sensible and a rook f293 could
be an even stronger fork
against the queen but i feel like i mean
i feel like an ali reza move
is to take on d4 and what aryan can try
here is this move knight a5 and the way
that this should be thought of is i'm
trying to get your queen
off of this diagonal so that i can take
the rook
but there is just no way that this is
going to work i mean with such an
abundance of pieces there is just no way
even something as simple as queen d5
preserves
the queen on on that long diagonal so
super tempting but ali reza continuing
to think here nine minutes for six yeah
i was just gonna say
in the clock situation in this game it's
already
looking precarious in the game we just
came from but here i mean
12 minutes to white against nine for
black with still
20 uh 17 moves to make uh we'll come
right back to this game but let's just
see a quick tweet
by uh grand master jonathan tissel
saying fiorugia has ability to inject
brain bending complications into
positions is amazing
very hard to study and emulate but worth
trying
or just watch and enjoy tata steel
keep the tweets coming we love to hear
from you dania what do you make
i am just going to watch and enjoy but i
jonathan uh tisdale yeah i've heard a
lot about him he's a great commentator
uh himself man of many talents and uh
that's a great that's a great way to
phrase
you know what alireza's talent partially
consists of it's just
i mean carl khan it doesn't matter what
the opening is he will find a way
as uh grandmaster tisdale is saying to
unbalance the position to create chances
and uh
to make the game fun uh for everyone
involved particularly commentators who
like
unbalanced games i don't know anything
of those though
another idea by the way here is to go
not knight g3 but bishop
to d3 and one thing that caught my eye
is if rook f2
first of all you can fork on h3
immediately you can also go bishop h4
um i just thought i saw a funny
checkmate look at this checkmate knight
h3
that's just nasty little stuff that's
just nasty stuff now you don't want to
play in order to deliver such a
checkmate you want to play objectively
but
that's just an example of how nasty this
position can be alireza though needs to
make a decision fast he's got seven and
a half minutes and counting
he needs to make a decision very fast
let's very quickly go to a game between
two of our co-leaders harry krishna and
fabiano carrana
a lot has changed here what is going on
well definitely fabi's still pressing
the gas pedal down he's definitely
better
now what we need to notice here and he's
been nurturing his initiative for a
while now he did eventually put the
knight on f4
i won't uh delve too deeply into some of
the details here long story short they
traded knights
fabi got a very strong pass bond he
preserved his monster bishop
which of course exerts such strong
pressure on the d4 pawn
hare krishna attempting to halt the
progress of the pawn as fabi
given that he has the bishop is opening
up the position which would make sense
hari krishna redeploying his knight and
putting it on e5 trying to make the most
out of that knight so
this is the position currently on the
board fabby contemplating his next move
now what
should fabby do here well definitely he
should try to harness
the strength of this pawn on c4 but
harry krishna has positioned his pieces
in such a way
as to make further well that has nothing
to do with anything has to make further
progress of the pawn
impossible i wanted to highlight the c3
square not the d3 square
is rookie for me is rookie for a threat
right now
oh actually it is uh rookie four would
potentially pick off that pawn so
definitely something fabby has to factor
in
i thought of maybe queen d4 keeping the
queen central
but i agree i mean rookie four here uh
but here i can give you a check
and then i can notice that the queen and
the rook are on the same diagonal and
play bishop f5
but uh even something like as simple as
you know queen c3 could be
quite a robust uh defensive con
construction here so
fabio with a pretty big decision on his
hands i think bishop f5
is another move that came to mind the
pawn is untouchable
due to the back rank devastating
background check on d1 forcing white to
give up his queen
so lots of candidate moves here even
rook d4 fabby
i think this decision is uh is quite
important another threat by the way that
can be hidden
is actually knight takes g6 if you look
at this bishop i like it that pawn on f7
is overloaded it's defending two things
at once
so whatever fab he does he also has to
defend against knight takes g6
and we see fabi taking his time these
guys i know you guys out there can't see
the move numbers they already on move
uh 35 so five but still still six moves
uh
two make um and
i think we should go back stick with the
uh the action let's go
back to um to yesipenko maybe again i
think
the time is picking down now and um
i think we have a hari krishna portrait
uh before
we do pantala hari krishna amazing chess
player let's
quickly maybe listen in on some
information about
that incredible player
i was pretty busy with various
uh various things but related to chess
obviously
in january you just look forward for why
kansai it's like
uh no wonder they call wimbledon of
chess
i prepared for this event uh not just
uh you know last week or something but
from some time ago and of course
since i played couple of events earlier
um
i could also you know test test the
variations and so on
the first time i played way back in 2001
and i think some of the participants
were not even born
so so many strong players world
champions and
not only that the competition gave
chances to many youngsters
like for example this one has many
youngsters to prove themselves
and to compete against the best players
well i'm not really aiming for some kind
of uh
muscles or like a professional athlete
to play
a long event like waikanse or many other
events
you need to have your mind fresh
and that can be achieved by staying
fit or to do some exercise so
for me it is quite important
always a pleasure having harry krishna
here
in vikenzi with us he's such a gentleman
and what a fantastic chess player
he really is a consummate professional
that's the word that comes to mind
professional
and i mean that in the best possible way
such a hard worker
and uh as you said just uh he's just so
nice so humble it's
just a pleasure to have these kinds of
people in the chess world
uh speaking of pleasures in the chess
world alireza for russia
the young star he is a position that he
has against our atari is exploding
shall we check in on how his attack is
going let's go
there um i see the rook sitting on the
for dania you call this well bishop g4
first so first he decided to tighten up
the pressure
makes perfect sense on the knight and
once he's done that here comes
rook takes d for this idea that we
discussed once again knight takes d4
knight h3 is no longer possible because
of rook takes h3 but queen g2
certainly still is and uh that is not
something aryan is considering how does
aryan defend here
can you imagine fiona having this with
nine minutes and i would still be
nervous for ali reza i mean six
this is not easy too man man man this is
hard
yeah but harry i feel like harry uh ali
riza you know he's so used like i'm
i'm actually surprised at how relaxed
how um i relax alireza looks we can
still see
like i think you can tell that the legs
are shaking under the
papers you know yeah
yeah constant motion and we have a move
uh by aryan but i mean ali rizza in
general is someone even you know when i
interview
him like he's constantly moving i don't
think i've ever
seen alireza see him stand still or sit
still
for more than a couple of seconds it's
he's he's in motion
uh and 96 check by arientari facing
black with a very urgent decision does
ali reza take or does he go king b8
intuitively i feel like this bishop on
e7 could be a valuable attacking piece
it might not seem that way now
but one could imagine a reality where
the bishop can potentially stick itself
on h4 and
uh maybe introduce further
discombobulation within white's ranks
on the other hand that knight on d6 is
sort of a thorn in black side
so a case could definitely also be made
for bishop takes e6 my hunch is that
both moves are probably okay
but here's what's great about aryan's
vote it faces black with
a decision and just by definition
alireza will have to take off
a chunk of his remaining time to make
that decision but he has made that
decision relatively fast he has indeed
gone
king to ba trying to preserve the status
quo the ball tossed back into aryan
tari's court he once again has to find a
move now what exactly is the threat here
that's actually not that easy to
determine i'm not sure
that black has anything immediate that
he's threatening i think aryan does have
one tempo
that he can use to coordinate his
defense maybe queen e3 just
bringing another defender in but then
this i mentioned the bishop bishop g5
becomes very
possible that knight once again tied
down to f3 oh
yeah i mean i don't really do he
probably has a temper right now but he
better use it wisely i mean
yeah i don't know how because everything
is wingy 3 92 check is a fork
yeah i mean the position is so i mean i
feel
really genuinely sorry for harry and
tommy having to figure this out
with eight minutes on the clock it feels
like i mean as you just
showed queen g3 there's a fork on it too
it feels like
i almost want to pass you know like i
feel like with every move i might
blunder something blunder for hang a
piece somewhere
indeed indeed and queenie has been
played
okay i think i have a good i have a good
handle on how these players i think but
here's the thing bishop g5
i well if fischer g5 i thought queen
takes d4 might be a move but actually
it's not you don't want to take the
queen
but you do want to go 92 followed by
knight takes d4 and you actually win the
queen
with the knight so the eval bar doesn't
like this move
for whatever reason i'm not exactly sure
why i'm trying to figure that out
um this is just so complicated and and
there's so much going on here maybe
it's just a computer you might take your
rook
with this and no with the queen ah but
but then but then there's this knight
right and then i take them out no no no
i was checking that as well but there is
maybe just king h1 the point of this
move is that you no longer can go to h3
with check you're just trying to avoid
the scariest part of the discovery um
and that might be possible so bishop g5
is one canada but that's not the only
move white is not actually threatening
anything and that's the important part
now black is a tempo
and now black has to figure out what to
do with it what if i
okay what if i give you a check on h3
sensible because you drive the king into
the pin but i'm not sure how to exploit
that then though
right there okay the computer does
not like here i can take on d4 already
bishop after we rook after we now it's
very important to keep this rook on c3
so that it pins the queen
and this is continues to be complex but
here the attack
kind of fizzles out i'll irisa under
five minutes now
if the clock is accurate what is the
move
man this is hard hard hard to determine
you always have to consider captures
here so maybe it's time for bishop takes
d6
although not just he takes c6 i don't
see how that benefits black
at all yeah
it makes those commentators looks like
look like fools like
there is something you guys have tried
like five moves already
you haven't figured it out yet keep
trying no i mean it might be something
as
calm as queen to d5 still not the move i
mean
but yeah i hope people can understand
that like this kind of position
requires tremendous engagement and and
finding the move and then
actually chatting is helping us out
bishop takes
h5 just simply taking oh just takes
that's like a classic uh i don't know
the evil but maybe the lr is wrong i
mean maybe it just drops and bishop g5
has been played
so you know we're all humans i know well
i've played i played thousands of games
i mean though just kidding ali reza is
a million times more skilled than yours
truly in these kinds of positions and
he's
uh kicked my butt plenty of times uh
with these kind of scintillating attacks
so once again to recap the bishop is
untouchable
what is the idea of bishop g5 the idea
is to set up a discover check
sorry to uh sorry i interrupt you but
we've had a result
in the game a young christian of do that
against anish giri that ended peacefully
as we see the players
get off the board there and that's kind
of what we expected we have further
trades we had a rook end game where
black's activity of his rooks
compensated for uh white's extra pawn
there's a full blockade going in
no need to continue this game as we have
a very professional high level draw but
let's
let's jump back i think everybody's
excited at how this game is unfolding i
know i knew drew
unbelievable unbelievable result here
i'm expecting king h1pion i feel like if
i can put myself in aryan's shoes
he is going to see the threat of knight
h3 is he going to think well how do i
avoid it
i think he might move his king of course
i can't predict the future but
that's that's my sense my feeling here
yeah i mean the problem is that white
king
is so incredibly weak wherever it is
when you're on h1 you're in the diagonal
with my queen
from c6 looking down at the king
if i go to g1 i feel like i'm stepping
into all
sorts of night shacks which i also don't
want to do
i mean i would love for my king to be
you know on b2 or somewhere far from the
danger zone but
that's a rather rather long a long run
and that's not gonna happen
yes it is no wouldn't it wouldn't that
be great it's like oh
this is paradise paradise awaits like
18 squares away but what else is there
to do other than queen i mean you could
you could go at it from the other side
you could move the queen back to e1 as
well
uh but this looks horrible i mean just
if you're moving something it's at least
you might
might as well make the king safer uh so
i i thinking h1 is really the only move
i'm just not seeing anything other than
that
but uh aryan now with dipping himself to
five minutes this is going to be an
amazing time scramble fiona we are in
for a treat
13 moves to go and they are playing a
blitz game and one of the sharpest
positions i've seen in this tournament
and aryan has just made a move rook
five wow okay i was going to point this
move out
i was going to point this move out but i
didn't think that it worked
but i guess i'm wrong oh oh my god this
is amazing
oh this is amazing so queen takes c5
look at this knight takes d4
i looked at this wait no no no this does
lose so what is his idea then maybe it's
i it's knight takes g5
it's to take the bishop i actually
didn't realize that it was hanging
it's to take the bishop on g5 and
there's no discovery along
this diagonal and um
if lyreza makes a preliminary check on
h3
then after the king moves away bishop
takes e3
rook takes c6 right uh and this is
everything's saying i'm just like taking
all the pieces and at the end of the day
it's two pieces for a rook with a
completely messy position it's
really anyone's game here that actually
might happen here let's see what else it
does
i wish i had about half an hour on our
on my commentary clock to to understand
to understand this position
the players have uh between themselves
less than 10 minutes to figure it out
and actually alireza um is starting to
look
uh like five minutes ago i was saying oh
he's looking calm
and collected but that's not the case
any longer well i think he missed rook
65 that's a brilliant move to find in
time for trenton and not only do you
wish
that you had 30 minutes on the
commentary clock i think both tari and
especially for rouge are wishing that
they had 30 minutes on the game clock
and uh ali raza is definitely
disconcerted i mean i think i
he definitely you know i think was
winning at some point
but it's so easy to miss these kinds of
moves when you feel like there's so many
threats like how could this possibly
work
this is not fair but when you've got a
lot of pieces hanging
really anything can happen there's it's
almost like a quantum position there's
there's a lot of chance uh that that
goes along with
these kinds of positions because you
know five pieces are hanging and uh
there's discovered checks all over the
place now two minutes for alireza what
is he going to do
how is this position going to fizzle out
let's see
yeah so we looked at queen takes uh
queen takes c5 of course the most
obvious move
what other options could he be
considering well i think this is the
other option it's knight h3 check versus
queen takes c5
off the top of my head i'm not seeing
any other moves and after queen c5
knight g5 this position has to be
evaluated
by ferusha because i mean
literally it is so wild that i mean you
can't move the rook the one thing that
we can notice here is this pin against
black's queen
he has just taken the rook by the way
you know
maybe we can take a page out of the
suggestion uh previously just take on h5
here basically
punt the ball and toss it back into
white's court so he's taken
and 1965 has happened okay now the
evolve bar is showing eight
yeah black is there some sort of
brilliant idea here
let's see apparently bishop e2 is the
move
bishop e2 what is what
is dania what is going on yeah so rookie
one i'm just trying to figure out what
the idea is
but that is the move and i'm
i mean maybe it's like queen b4 no i
guess not
jeez i i'm i'm just trying to like
orient myself oh rook d1
oh my god sack the queen we take c5
rookies
three that is insane and then the knight
defends the rook the king has to move
you take the queen your upper rook that
is the winning line
only has one minute 10 on the clock to
find it he has just made
a move 92 check he hasn't found it but
oh that's a big mistake and uh
how who can who can not understand that
i mean how do you even find that but
this was apparently winning an amazing
idea
just a little too once we make the time
control we'll have to show that again
that was just
an incredible line yeah really what
baroque won i mean
uh my job was an easy one because i was
basically fed bishop e2
and finding rookie one at that point
it's just a matter of eliminating all
the moves
by the way i see a comment in the chat
aloueta tilting bad i think alireza is
not tilting at all by the way
ali rizza would be tilting if as you say
someone you know tapped him on the
shoulder and said oh by the way bishop
2 instead of 92 was winning but the
players obviously have none of that
none of that knowledge nor do they
realize okay this is now plus white and
four
white and this position is so open
with the time situation i think all the
players are think i mean
they're not thinking of the outcome of
the game they're just trying to
calculate
as quickly as possible here bishop b2 is
i'm just gonna
say it i mean even with 30 minutes i
would say it's almost impossible i mean
this move is so
illogical because you basically just put
your bishop on this vulnerable square
and
if you don't see rook d1 then you would
never make such a move and seeing rook
d1 on demand in time pressure
i i mean i realized that watching from
the side
you know one might fail he's tilted or
he's i mean that has nothing to do with
it he's that these players are fully
focused
they are professionals and um the fact
that alireza misses an impossible win
does not in any way diminish
the quality of that effort that is being
put in absolutely and you cannot tilt if
you don't know
that you missed that you missed the
winning move and
i'm not gonna find out also i don't
think there's any chance you know
sometimes you get to the time control
and you think back and you're like oh
dan i missed
i missed something there but i don't
think this is gonna happen today if we
even make it
to the time control i don't think he's
gonna think back and think
oh i missed bishop e2 there i have a
feeling this game will end before the
time control well here aryan has a big
choice
even queen takes e2 was was possible but
then i realized black is rook to d2
check
the funny thing is if bishop takes c2
then white can give this check
and then win back the queen and win the
game so aryan has to calculate that as
well but the real
decision is between these two moves does
he play king h1
or does he play king to g2 the the
benefit of king to g2 is that the king
is a little bit more open if you think
about that king sitting on h1 right
it it's vulnerable in the future in way
in the future
to a checkmate on f3 if you imagine that
this knight disappears if you have some
sort of mass
trade um this opens the king up to more
tactics
whereas king g2 at least promises the
king an additional escape squad
too from that perspective alone king f2
uh king chu tu would make more sense but
that's of course not
a legitimate reason in such a sharp
position on the other hand if you're
staying on the g
file maybe you're worried that you're
opening yourself up to checks along the
g
file or tonight f4 so
yeah it's not exactly like unfortunately
i have ferrari ontario it's not exactly
like he has a
safe haven for his king no it's it's
you're choosing between the frying pan
you know the fire and the hurricane the
tornado and where do you go
which evil do you accept well he chose
the g2 fire and there we see
a close of a close-up of aluesa's clock
so even a few less seconds on the clock
than we see
on the screen just one minute twenty
four eleven
indeed and uh now yeah he's gotta find
something here
it things have definitely spiraled out
of control it's anybody's game it's so
unclear a move that comes to mind is a
check on d5
you can try to stabilize the situation
and in the event of king f2
that would i think be a very big blunder
due to this check on f4 so in this
position aryan would have to cover with
a knight
and probably with this knight in order
to leave the d6 knight which would
potentially set up checkmating ideas
along these lines i was calculating here
queen takes c5
probably this loses due to that check on
ffa
let's see if we can get the camera back
on alireza's face as the second stick
take down under 40 seconds now for ali
reza as he tries
uh tries his best to figure out his way
out of this maze but still
11 moves to make oh
there was a draw for there was a draw
for
accompanied king g2 and alireza
has accepted okay
and uh that's interesting i mean we can
understand that from tari's perspective
who had been
you know crushed or seemed to be crushed
at the
start of the attack and uh drawfur is
actually and i i realize that people
will be very surprised but but this is a
legitimate technique
that is advanced in in some books where
you basically you offer the draw and
and alireza i think did a very good
thing to accept that drop what aryan was
also kind of trying to do if alireza had
declined the draw and made a further
mistake
that would have merely contributed to
the regret that he would be feeling
uh at the game because alireza can
definitely sense that he missed
something he doesn't know where it was
but he can definitely send it and we can
totally understand aryan's place
perspective here i mean surviving this
insane attack by ali reza and a half a
point is definitely something that he
will cherish
as a result and a good job by alirez
that's it to seek his comp
absolutely i think for us as
commentators and for the
the viewers of course it's an
anti-climactic
and to to a spectacular game uh i saw
questions why
why would alireza accept well first of
all we saw his clock it's a very well
timed uh a very well timed draw for
by ariane towie uh you know when you
have 30 seconds on the clock
i don't think either of the players knew
what the evaluation
was of the position simply because it
was such a crazy position where
indeed both of them realize okay neither
of us are winning or losing right now
but we will be losing if we make one
single mistake
and so i think from that point of view
and none of the players can really be
faulted
yeah before we review the the results
that are in let's very quickly
run through the winning line again so in
this position right before the end
bishop to e2
was the key move now this attacks the
rook if the rook takes the knight
then the d uh the d files this is also a
very nice line king f2
now what you need to do here is dislodge
the king from the queen you give a check
on f1
and then you give a check on e1 the king
has to take the rook and then not only
does the queen pick up the queen
but it also picks up the rook so black
wins in this line
but that's uh not even the end of it
rook to e1
is therefore the only possible retreat
square now
rook d1 follows sacrificing the queen
white has to accept it otherwise he just
loses the rook
and after rook takes c1 check the king
is only one square
and now that is accompanied with knight
to d3 track hitting the king
forking the queen and also defending the
rook the king must move away from the
rook
white black takes the queen and black is
winning here he is simply
up a rook but who can blame uh farouza
for not seeing this with about a minute
on his talk nonetheless an incredible
winning line
and uh the game concludes in a draw so i
think if he had found this we could have
given him i don't even know if there
is a brilliant surprise here or not but
if there were i think we could have
given it to him right here and
right here and then after just four
rounds
and shall we go back to nils grandelias
and andre esepanko which was the other
game
which seemed to be headed straight for a
big time scramble
absolutely and maybe yeah definitely so
we've had three draws by the way today
von forest carlson duda geary just to
recap in tari
farushaf all ended in draws and they've
all been very very combative
um but some of the most interesting
results are yet
to come so what's going on here looks
like andre is holding things together
fiona
yeah so far so good my eyes immediately
went to the clock
so both players two minutes uh they'll
move 34 which means
seven moves to play still four nils and
six moves to play for yasipanko
let's maybe just click through the the
last few moves that we missed
sure and uh basically what happened was
after knight five knight e4 i think we
were seeing this
niels uh decides to take that bishop
and ruin white's pawn structure andre
deciding to keep the knight on f5 that's
basically his only active piece but he
manages to kind of get his pieces
going again you know get the bishop
active that rook kind of tied down to e5
uh much like in first atari so neil's
saying get out of there now he goes rook
d to d5 he's trying to put the pressure
and put that heat on the knife
you mentioned checkmating ideas fiona if
the knight ever moves away
boom rook h5 and this is a very pretty
mate so
he's trying to tie the knight down to f5
uh andre
uh offering up a rook trade and now
neil's getting his queen to an active
square
this is crazy i mean this is so hard to
defend and the point is if bishop h3
i think that niels has a very very
devilish idea cooked up
he can take on d1 or maybe even queen h5
immediately and the point is that queen
takes h3
is going to be uh is going to be a very
very big threat in these positions i i
think i'm not finding the most accurate
execution of this
but something to that effect is going to
be super nasty so
andre going rook to d4 using his rook to
protect the bishop i think that's a very
accurate
accurate move here wow and
we we just came from one messy position
no rest for the wicked uh dania
how do you okay how do you even start to
to evaluate
uh what's what's going on here
well this is not quite as complicated as
uh atari farouza but it's it's
definitely up there
i think the key question is well one of
black's major strengths
lies in this x-ray that the bishop is
exerting on white's king
uh weiss key defensive idea is that he's
positioned as minor pieces in such a way
as to make progress on the king side
very difficult so
the tempting move is definitely h5 i
think it's tempting to chase the bishop
but now it parks itself on h3 and the
bishop is pretty safe here
so i'm actually not sure how niels how
exactly niels can increase the pressure
i mean he might
at some point want to take the rook but
then the queen replaces the rook and
still the rook on e5
is is pinned so you know
and he's got to make a move as well
i was just saying under one minute and
as i said it
right i didn't know he uh he gains just
time in his life when he asks i just
want a minute here just give me a minute
nils just played f6 by the way if i'm
seeing that correctly
okay that's that's interesting so he's
trying to submit okay so what i think
he's trying to do is
in the event that a queen appears on d4
it will not be
x-raying that rook it looks like a
weakening move but the reality is
it's actually strengthening the king's
defenses uh because the king can always
escape to h7 so i think he's building up
up this little pawn chain to prevent
white from
trying to checkmate him at some point on
g7 also this is kind of like a waiting
move as the thinker wants to find
another improving move which in time
pressure is
extremely difficult i say panko has just
drawn his bishop back to
age three you know i think maybe just
one quick word i think this is a spot
where i think niels
experience uh could play a big a big
role
niels has been competing at the highest
level you know he talked in the video
about like playing here in vikings 11
years ago i mean 11 years ago
andreas panko was only 7 and uh just
making his first
first steps on the chessboard indeed and
uh
nils is also a great blitz player and
that should not be underestimated i've
you know i've lost him several times
he's he's very fast
you know he's obviously an amazing
tactician and by the way queen h5 here
is very tempting i mentioned this
previously
uh trying to perhaps set up some sort of
a queen sacrifice
uh but i guess we're about to see his
movie goes bishop to d7 instead he goes
after this knight on five again
very sensible i think that's a great
move and he ties down all of white's
pieces now they all have to defend this
knight on f5
necedenko has to find yet another
accurate defensive move
neil's doing everything that he can and
you can just see i agree with you fiona
his experience
coming to light here as he finds one
excellent move after another maintaining
full pressure on one's position
yeah what do you do um what do you
interestingly actually there on the
camera do you see neil's just giving a
little shake of the head then a little
stare i
i love watching the players when they're
so short
so short on time but yeah i mean it's
all the emotions come
bubbling up you just can't hide any of
it when you've got a minute that's not
the priority the priority
is to is to refocus and and focus
every fiber of your brain and your being
to find the correct move
and the emotions just come pouring out
when you've got a minute and you're
either disappointed you're happy
you'll see all sorts of things happen as
i said bank of hesitating and now he's
about to make a move
yeah even yes we can't see his face but
we saw the head shake even from the
the behind camera it's tough
it's a tough spot okay how do you deal
with with that
um well i think he might end up taking
the rook and
slightly which slightly diminishes the
pressure on the knife
it doesn't really go both fully danny
i'm sorry to cut you off we have an
interview with
uh arianna i was not sure what was going
on i saw the engine now saying zeros but
uh i wasn't sure i thought he will uh
zeros but even then
yeah even then i mean when you have some
solo when you're so low on time anything
can happen really so three results were
possible but i thought
so there was something like a little bit
of fear involved in the decision
and the main reason was because i i
thought i was just lost like three moves
before
so i was just so happy to get a half a
point you know i was sure i'm gonna lose
at some point
well according to dangers you probably
were losing
but you were also winning at some point
yeah this was just an insane game it was
so crazy it was just like
mental torture from the start you have
to think about so much and
it's just so much to calculate all the
time so it's definitely my most
difficult game
here so far was it your strategy to get
like a tactical
game or you just couldn't manage to keep
it strategical
the thing is uh it's like it's actually
the most stupid thing you can do against
feruja together like i wouldn't
if i wasn't going to say that but yeah
yeah like you get a tactical crazy
position against ferguson that's what he
eats for breakfast you know so
just maybe he can
maybe he's as good as magnus in those
positions but there was no way to avoid
it for you
i could have avoided it it was very
stupid i played g4 i went for a crazy
game i should just uh
take on c5 and you have better there but
the problem was i couldn't really
just couldn't find my fight my demons i
just played g4
and uh then of course this is position
for ferruja and he played well i thought
i was
doing well i mean g4 i thought it should
work for me but
i have to check it it was crazy okay but
now
after everything is finished it's a
pretty okay feeling i guess
yeah i mean uh before the game drove
with whites it's a result yeah
but just like 20 minutes ago i thought i
was i was going to lose so
a bit happy to get a half a point okay
good luck
thank you
danny i think we can address what uh
what aryan said in the interview but
let's
first follow the end of the of this time
scramble between
andre yancy panko and niels grandelius
continuing to put the pressure on now he
infiltrates the second rank with his
rook
uh the most immediate response here
would be rook f2
but um something tells me that
that probably black has something to the
effect of knight e5 trying to dislodge
the queen
or maybe even bishop c6 here uh in
response to rook f2 andre
again one minute and he's got to find
something very very difficult here he is
definitely worse and two
critical moves to be made these are the
two longest moves perhaps of his career
that he's got to make in one minute yeah
and we see him hovering
over the queen queen a8 is on the board
indeed we need a check makes sense king
h7 is going to follow and i wonder how
he will follow that up
maybe he wants to just snap that pawn
off on a6 and maybe he just wants to say
all right
yolo you know maybe and um
which is no easy task because niels will
have to make his 40th move as well let's
take
check out what estepanka will cook up
here
so the last move uh the last move now
before
they get an additional 50 minutes is it
gonna be the yolo
queen a6 or what else
i i mean that looks so dangerous though
to abandon the king like that but on the
other hand i mean
it can pose nils with a very difficult
challenge in his 40th move
which he will also have only a minute
for so
man i okay queen e4 queenie for
getting the queen back to the center now
obviously
he is allowing niels to take on on b2
and maybe his his idea is to go 97 maybe
he wants to
create kind of a pin that doesn't look
particularly effective i think niels can
just grab the pawn to be honest
i i'm and call a bluff on andre's move
so i'm just not sure what it what it is
exactly andre is is planning but
i guess we're about to find out 50 moves
added that is still of course a relief
and neil's with one move to play until
the time control let's see what it is
he was hovering over the king area so
at least at first sight doesn't look
like he's gonna snatch that pawn
and he has just come back king h8
okay i'm not sure exactly what he didn't
like about this
i mean i'm really wondering what it is
in rook b2 and
i don't see anything right off the bat
but maybe there was something he didn't
like maybe it was knight takes g7 maybe
something crazy
but in any case they have made the time
control with niels preserving for sure
his advantage
we will monitor how andre defends this
and the other games but first i think we
are
going to take a quick break aren't we
we'll be right back
[Music]
and we are back here from vacancy with
all the action
promont for what a day it has been
so far dania indeed it's been a day of
incredible action and
the results belie the uh nature of that
action as we've had another result
uh bansalahari krishna and uh fabiana
caruana drawing their game
it seemed that fabiano and of course
that the game of the day so far has been
ferocious game which also ended in a
draw but it seemed that fabi had
had pressure going but he did in fact
allow
um this knight takes g6 move and what
ended up happening is that he played
quindi when he saw this
and he was able to distract white stroke
from
its attack of the bishop however what he
may not have taken into account is that
harry krishna gets actually
three pawns for the piece or maybe
caruana saw this and just didn't see
anything better
and they repeat moves three pawns for
the piece is perfect compensation
so caruana saw no need no reason to
continue and rightly so
that game also ending in a draw and
alexander don't join game is also i
think going to finish in a draw very
very shortly so we see
a lot of these games ending in draws but
not for lack of trying by any of the
players
oh and maybe well maybe let's catch up
quickly on the three games that we still
have ongoing and then we
can come back briefly on some of the
things uh arientari mentioned in his
interview and some of the madness that
happened in that game indeed and it's
been a while since we've checked into
the end game that
mvl has against antonio uh so let's
um take a look at that one always saw
the transition into the end game and
uh they they start taking each other's
pawns rook c6 is a very tricky move by
the way threatening
rook takes f5 and creating the pin
against the g pawn
so anton had to move his king and nbl
coming up with an extra pawn here at the
end of the day
but um anton is very active pieces he's
got the act of rook
he's got a bishop that can at the right
moment fianchetto on b7
and really started an attack against the
king i think nbl is planning to meet
that move with d5
intercepting the bishop so anton has to
be a little bit careful here
but i don't think that black should be
worse i think if if enzo makes a couple
of accurate moves here
he should be able to make the drawing
he's got plenty of time
and now that the time control has been
made i might have
jinxed it today you know i came into the
day saying it's
the day before the rest day the players
are all gonna be fighting
i mean they don't get no don't get me
wrong not fighting they're all going to
be out for blood they can rest
tomorrow but might have jinxed it and
it could be our first uh our first
entirely
peaceful day here in vik
absolutely and and um you know we we
probably will see this game and in the
draw we'll see
don chinko voy tushak almost certainly
in a draw and that basically leaves us
at pengo grandelias and it seems also
like assetfenko
having made the time control is making
some progress towards stabilizing that
situation so indeed we might see
a day of peace just to address a point
that i think some people are making
about the atari game i would really push
back on
on criticizing aryan too much for that
draw for or ali raza for accepting it
uh and one must realize that it is
important
to keep the fans interest at heart i you
know we certainly are the first
to say that we like bloodbaths and we
like the games to continue
uh but we must also realize that these
players have to put their interests
first and if they
you know if aryan feels uncomfortable
playing then and he feels that a half a
point is a good result then
that that is a sensible thing to do from
his perspective and that also has to be
understood
so i would caution against being too
critical of those
sorts of things these players are all
here to fight and there's no question
about about it in my mind
i couldn't agree more and i mean even
the word choice by ariane tower in his
interview
if i recall correctly literally called
it meant mental torture
you know like i think uh we cannot
overstate just how demanding such a game
is and
these guys were navigating these complex
positions from such an early point
in the game and yeah i mean i can agree
more with you that absolutely none of
the players
can be criticized of course we would all
loved would we would all have loved to
see how the game played out but
i think absolutely a fair result yeah
definitely
and uh as we see anton going rook c1
harassing mvl's bishop
the question is where do you put that i
mean bishop b3 seems
seems like a pretty sensible move and
perhaps anton wants that rook to have
access i don't know exactly to what i
mean c7 doesn't seem like a particularly
juicy square
but maybe he wants some clarity in the
position rookie 8 rookie one is another
active idea here it's it's hard to get a
grasp entirely on this position as i
said emil is up a pawn
but his pawns are all over the place and
with only three pawns left it just
doesn't seem like that material
advantage should be
enough to win him the game really or to
generate significant chances
we will keep checking in on this game
yeah shall we quickly see
uh alexander and donchenko and radius
lavoiterscheck which um
[Music]
has once again a lot more pieces have
come off the board
since we uh last last left it off
right and uh alexander after a very long
thing
in this bishop and game go get ghost c2
and i think this is a dead draw now
um of course despite white's extra pawn
black has very active pieces and he's
got a complete blockade
over the sea pawn that sivan is not
going anywhere
and um i think what alexander might have
been contemplating is where to put the
king white actually has to be a little
bit careful
if he had played king a4 i think that
would have been asking for trouble if
black skin can get to c4
uh then black actually generates very
significant winning chances because all
of these pawns are on
squares that are not very desirable for
white's bishop and uh
as soon as white's bishop leaves g2 then
black's bishop can infiltrate to f1 so
alexander actually if anybody has to be
careful
it's probably alexander and now we might
see a repetition along the lines of
bishop b5
king b3 bishop c4 this game will end in
a draw really any second
yeah which will leave us with only uh
two games the game we just came from
maxine verchilagrav against uh david
anton and
let's go back there andreas panko
against niels grandelius who we were
just watching make the the first time
control before our break
indeed and knight h4 was andre
essepenko's
move executed fairly quickly yes he
tries to yes sorry to interrupt you
we're gonna go to an interview with
fabiano uh
karana will come back to this game right
after
and you escaped me but that was a game
to discuss i mean who am i
but according to me it was one
of the best game i've seen in a long
time what is your opinion on that
yeah i think it was close to being one
of my best games i've ever played
um but yeah not quite i mean you also
have to to finish the game off
um but yeah i was actually a bit
surprised because
when he played bishop f6 i thought this
move was losing because of what happened
in the game
and i was kind of shocked using play
knight takes c3 which looked like
much more messy i mean i and at least
there it gave me like many options while
here he was kind of forcing
um so i thought he would play knight c3
he played bishop six which i i thought
was kind of crazy because it
goes by force into the position we had
we're after but still you spent like 15
or 20 minutes in that position why was
that
um well i still had uh had to make sure
um
i mean it's still very complicated and i
didn't want to to rush with my
my moves and um and also i was like not
entirely sure to take on h7 or to play
rook t5 first it wasn't
and completely obvious choice but i
rejected it because if he plays g6 my
attack sort of finishes
and when we got to the position after
king h8 i
i kind of knew that bishop d4 was an
option because i'd spent quite a bit of
time looking at the position
before we got there and um
and i was hoping there would be more
like i would i was looking at queen h3
queen h7 it's the forcing checks where i
take on g6 he takes on b2 and i play
king b1
and here he has to make a quiet
defensive move rookie seven because i
have a
threat made of queen of seven a thread
of queen of seven mate
and um and then i thought there should
be something winning there but i
couldn't see it
so i eventually settled on bishop d4
which was not really what i wanted
because the game kind of continues and
continues and continues
and uh maybe i should have just gone for
it but i really wasn't sure
um but i was very happy i with this
queen f7 all this stuff it looked
winning
after queen a2 i felt like it was
winning i had about three minutes left
um my first instinct was rook g3
uh it threatens rook a3 trapping the
queen it also threatens like rook h3
queen g6
if he takes the pawn it's winning and
then i i spend like
more or less two and a half of my three
minutes because after queen a1 king d2
king h7
i couldn't like finish him off i was
very surprised
rookie 39 he has like this construction
it's probably still winning but it was
like
somehow i was um yeah i i
don't like forcing um well it's all very
forcing for him
so it feels like um i should be able to
uh to calculate this to a win but maybe
i started in the wrong place with rook
g3
uh and i if i had started with like rook
takes g6 and i had
that i would have probably just just
played this and gone to a
pretty trivial winning ending where he
takes upon b2 i play rook g3 and
he has to trade queens on e4 and it
wasn't clear to me that this was winning
uh over the board but i didn't have
enough time to really
to verify it but after rook a3 it's
actually very very trivial
uh and in the game i just made a one
stupid move i think
the main reason i can blame myself for
not winning this is that i played rookie
one
if i had played a4 um
which was like basically i
i was going to play a4 and then i
thought i'll play rookie one and
paralyze him for a move and
and this was just a terrible blunder
after that it becomes very difficult to
win
but a4 i think i would have cleaned up
the game pretty easily if i played that
so yeah it was like just one regret
during that game
yeah and the ending is also probably
difficult
because you realize you sort of spoiled
it
already a little bit yeah of course
rookie one it
was a disappointment also in terms of um
still fighting for a win after it
becomes quite difficult i mean i was
told that if i had played
like king c3 at kv2 at some point it was
winning
but i i don't think i can even think in
this direction to
to put my king on b2 and i'm not even
sure if it was
100 winning i mean some strong engines
are
are saying why it might win but
but i can't really blame myself for
things which don't even come to my mind
so so the main regret i have is that i
didn't play a4
okay thank you great game not a good
result for you
thanks okay
so fabi there uh today mostly talking
about
the spectacular game he played yesterday
against jan christos duda and well
as he said his main regret is not going
for
not having gone for that a4 move in in
the ending
indeed and uh you know as he mentioned
it's it's painful because
it's really would have been as he said
one of the games that he ever played and
it still is i think that the fact that
the game and the draw doesn't take away
entirely from
some of the amazing things that he did
in that game but nonetheless speaking
very frankly
was fabi about some of his experiences
in that game and speaking of draws
we have another one for you
yeah niels was pressing pressing
pressing but in the end this move knight
h4
uh something niels didn't like about the
position maybe he still had a slight
advantage
but deciding instead two repeat moves
here the computer
does show an advantage for him i would
suppose uh instead of king
uh h8 maybe the move king g8 and king f7
would
extend the game but one can understand
that like this king on f7 does seem
quite weak
the pawn on a6 is hanging and i just
think the players are absolutely
exhausted and
you know we we can just see it you know
they're they're they don't want to lose
as you said fiona before the rest stand
yeah um you know as the games start
winding down
uh the players might have an early early
end and i don't think anybody really
minds
they have a couple more hours we'll have
plenty more rounds still
nine more rounds after after this one
that does mean we only have
two games remaining indeed uh both of
them
looks like they should be headed towards
draw maybe mvl now with the best chances
of still
getting a little something out of
today's round
yeah especially because the time
situation not anton's friend is david
taking a lot of time burning through his
clock you're trying to find the most
accurate way
to develop the maximum compensation for
the pawn
without a doubt the position remains
drawn but there's a lot of possibilities
for that he has to work through i mean
rook t8 is one option
uh that seems very sensible he can give
a check on b7 that's another option but
this might lead to a slightly inferior
rook end game after bishop f3 i think
that was mbl's idea with his last-minute
bishop p2
i think rook d8 seems to be more
flexible from that point of view
but um yeah i mean black is very
compacter he's got everything protected
and white
as i mentioned earlier has pawns
scattered all over the board so
definitely anticipating a draw here but
david will have to be a little bit
accurate here without
a doubt we'll come back today well just
before we went to the interview let's go
back there you were
explaining the intricacies of that
bishop ending
uh in donchenko against reuters
well i think there's there isn't too
much to explain here i think the only
thing
if anybody has winning chances here i
thought it might actually be black and
black can try to come around with this
king and force zusma
and the thing about zugzwan here is if
white has to move his bishop
then uh there is this move bishop to d1
and you know the bishop comes around and
collects that pawn on h3 now we see from
the evil bar that
even this position is is drawn somehow
i'm not exactly sure how and i think
maybe it has to do with the move bishop
d1 check i don't know
uh but but it seems to me that uh this
is not a very desirable situation for
alexander but i don't see how he avoids
it because white's king
he's going to have to move his bishop
eventually because the thing is
white's king is going to get what's
called shouldered right white is in
zugzwan
and every time he moves his king black
inches closer to the pawn
so i think alexander he's taken a lot of
time here i think he's calculated some
sort of a draw
uh after this move bishop f3 so i'm not
uh losing faith in his ability to make
the draw here but
this does look kind of scary and i think
radoslav has absolutely nothing to lose
he has to try
the move king a4 and he has just played
it yeah i mean it's such an instructive
end game this one that the side
with the pawn up is actually uh the one
who's fighting
fighting for his life yeah and this
actually might be
i'm actually starting to get quite
concerned because i'm not really
seeing exactly what the draw is in this
position
uh in addition black doesn't even have
to hurry black can go king b3 first
and stick the king on b2 and
you know only when the king is maximally
close to the pawn now you can go bishop
f1
and uh let me tell you and okay maybe
king e1
and if you take on h3 this is a funny
situation white wins because the bishop
is boxed in
but here's what what can be done here
you can try to go
no you can't try to go i don't know what
i was going to say i mean maybe bishop
d3
and like bishop c4 but you see the
problem is i just don't see the zuswan
here
so maybe this is somehow winning through
some miraculous sequence of bishop moves
but i'm not quite seeing i do think that
this is going to happen as alexander
does indeed
play the move bishop f3 incredible fiona
effort by radoslav
to really manufacture winning chances
that's kind of unthinkable when you
thought about
what position occurred on the board
alexander is definitely kicking himself
here
yeah he really is and i was just
thinking i for his
for his sake i really hope he can hold
on because
we already talked about losing before a
rest
day is painful full stop but i mean i
said a few hours ago i remember saying
yeah alexander is playing for two
results here
everything is under control and it
seemed like things were under control
but somehow um
right at it has a i think it's very
impressive how he's managed to somehow
create
chances here yeah it really is it's
and and bishop and games are among the
trickiest in chess
because they create always this
deceptive image
that that it's a dead draw you know it's
a fortress but zooxbang always plays a
role because you don't have a lot of
pieces left
and uh there's a lot of bishop end games
that are kind of exactly like this that
one side is of a pawn or it's equal
material and you just
assume that it's a draw and then all of
a sudden you realize that
uh one side is in zouksvang and has to
allow the other side to keep making
progress so
the other thing that really hurts white
is is pawn end games are unthinkable
uh because the king just collects all of
white's pawns the king activity here
is uh is is totally devastating king e3
king c4 and then king d4
so this concept of shouldering is very
important and yeah maybe we can announce
who our
who our second guest of the day is going
to be because it will
be very interesting to hear what he
makes
what he makes of this position
absolutely and
no better person to have uh in order to
assess the senior than the legend grand
master boris
gelfand uh who again really needs no
introduction
super grand master a world champion
contender
a you know participant in countless
super tournaments throughout the years
uh achieved the high rating of i think
27 80 plus
boris is uh a professional an amazing
player
and author and just a legend who is
still
maintaining his very very high level
right even as he gets older
sorry we have an interview with niels
grandelia so let's
let's go there before we get borison
yes do i have to be angry to you today
yeah i guess i guess you have to sort of
out of nothing i checked your position
after 20 moves
and the engine said that you were much
better
yeah that was my impression as well at
some point
i think he should try to just liquidate
and trade as much as possible but
he kept the position fluid for one or
two moves too much
and suddenly i have just taken over
completely after i get this d5 in and
i'm
so active and his king is very
vulnerable but it took me too much time
to find
this out and then in the time travel i
played very very poorly
and your chances vaporized yeah
yeah i mean first of all it looked very
promising with the attack
but even 40 what we got i could probably
just
have picked up a pawn or two instead of
what i was was trying to repeat the
position once and then on move 41
consider whether i should
pick up the pawns or make the draw but
he didn't
in 41 he played on or he played another
move and secured the draw so that was
very very stupid had i had a couple of
more minutes i would just have picked up
some pawns and
don't know if i would win but very good
chances at least
and it must have been an intense game
today because you
entered the press room without realizing
you're still the leader
yeah yeah i mean after missing so many
chances it feels a bit strange but on
the other hand i also made some good
moves again today so
i'm overall not too dissatisfied it's
just nice to be playing some chess
okay and two and a half out of four
before the tournament
you probably would have signed
immediately for that score apparently
but okay it's still nine games it's
basically a full tournament left
so anything can happen of course okay
good luck thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
neil's there kicking himself after the
draw
today um dania we're going to take
a quick break and we will bring on the
legend
i can't wait boris girlfriend don't go
anywhere guys you're in for a treat with
this one
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to
todd steele and
as promised we are joined by a legendary
guest
it is an honor to have in the studio
grand master super grandmaster boris
galfond world champion contender
and uh for many many decades one of the
top players in the world boris
uh big honor thank you so much for
joining us thank you for inviting me
it's an
honor for me to be a guest on such a
good in a good company and then such a
legend tournament yeah
thank you well um speaking of the
legendary tournament i
i certainly want to get your input on
the ongoing games but first uh maybe a
couple of questions about your extensive
experience you of course have played in
vikanze many many times
any highlights or or stories or
experiences that come to mind in in bike
well it's quite a few unfortunately i
didn't
do that well normally in like i won
in my first appearance 92 i typed this
solo
with the equal tie break then i won
candidates matching against adams in 94
but then okay my tournaments were from
horrible to
decent my performances but the
atmospheres uh
it's always fantastic it's as i
understand
unfortunately this year uh
it's it's wonderful the tournament takes
place but still
it's a pity this legendary atmosphere
with uh you know
hundreds of uh spectators watching and
you know after the round you go to eat
some way and the
players who play a other section
sit next to you you discuss games all
this great experience
hopefully we will be back next year for
everyone
yeah we're all definitely hopeful for
that well speaking of these unusual
circumstances have you been
participating in any of the online
events what are your what is your take
on
how chess has adapted in the covet age
yeah yeah okay chess it's hard to say
but i think
uh my feelings are just adapted the best
way possible of course
all this uh offline i went uh are very
rare and some of them where i had to
take place where
canceled at the last moment and probably
to a
good reason yeah probably it was a wise
decision by organizers
but i played few online events
unfortunately there are not that many of
high level
i played blitz event i played this great
legend event
some rapid
bleeds but play some training games with
friends
but okay it's very good to see
tournaments and
given the posse is a choice
i think chess had adopted pretty
decently
mm-hmm that's that's an interesting take
and
in addition to participating actively in
tournaments
uh to this day you've also written
recently a series of very high
highly uh regarded books on decision
making in chess
i've ha have been have read two of them
and greatly enjoyed them positional
dynamic and now technical decision
making in chess could you tell us a
little bit boris about your experience
uh writing these books what are these
what did you try to largely target in
these books and
maybe any other experiences of writing
these these very well received
uh recent books thank you
actually the two books you mentioned
about
positional decision making and dynamic
decision making
were out uh years ago
and for all these years we worked with
my co-author jaka bogorton
the next book and we produced so much
material that we had no choice
but to split some into volumes technical
decision
and the major peace and the game
and they basically be
there are two layers i want to underline
this is books
one of them is some really incredible
beauty of chess which underlined by
uncovered by deep analysis
but also maybe even more important
the method to think in this kind of
position because
what it was my dear
and my co-author shared it i think
this means incentives that nowadays is
also engines
uh many chess say francis players got
lost
because they say and they say that let's
say chose remove
show the same assessment and it's very
difficult to tell between them
and we try to describe it from human
point of view
which move is better which move is
less good which move allows
you to achieve better result
how to think rather than because
engines they brought a lot to our life
but also
they started you know to take a role and
you know mislead many times a
people who want to analyze chess and to
run from
that's that's really fascinating so do
you feel that some young players maybe
are
misguided in their approach they're over
relying on the engine
and and that's stifling some development
of certain players
yeah i do believe so actually during
this
lockdown i made quite a few online
lectures uh camps with a
a lot of really basically
vast majority of the best talents in the
world
went through them and i noticed that and
i tried to
share my knowledge and discoveries not
only
from material from the books but also
from other
experiences and games uh how to use
engine to the best
of them and how to try to learn to think
in the most productive way
that makes that makes a lot of parts are
learning each day there is no limit
i learned myself each day you know let's
say you analyze some games
and the engine suggests the first layer
but when you dig
you realize that sometimes
quite often the first impression maybe
it's not the most practical
or the most
decent decision
that's i mean that's really interesting
i think that's a book that many many
people should get
across all levels and speaking of well
technical end games and
interesting positions maybe we could get
your take on the two remaining end games
and your general impressions of
this edition of tata steel and maybe we
could switch to the the donchun
avoid the shotgun game first that seems
to be the most interesting one do you
feel that black has any any chances here
let me see let me see
let me see i i opened it on my board
yeah so it looks like bishop c2 probably
it's a calculation of black
i don't think there is there are two
ways for black to progress in my opinion
one is uh you know try to zucks one but
maybe it's not realistic
another to grab h3o we have to calculate
if you can be in time or c4
would be like bishop f5 if bishop f1
doesn't win
now i don't think any other idea exists
so bishop f1 what we do probably bishop
d3 d3
bishop h3 c4 right yeah
c4 bishop g4 and bishop g2 there are two
moves yeah
right so efficient g4 c5
just h3
ah bishop f1 maybe bishop f three books
three they take one h3
yup take one e4 and now
yeah this seems like black has some
chances here can we
maybe we have to go deeper i have a
feeling that it
must be some semi force line maybe
where we stopped maybe bishop g4 israeli
bishop f3
try to speculate by
transformation opponent game right
you know the margin is very
narrow
after bishop takes g4 i mean it seems to
force bishop h3
oh yeah then let's see is then okay then
c5 and
bishop gt2
maybe we can go bishop d3 and the both
of
the sides will clean but no chat
and probably blacker it's rather black
or
in trouble because we can meet them you
know it's just mating yeah queen c3 and
so many threats wow that's very cool
yeah it's an
incredible line we discovered yeah yeah
queen c1 is not possible and wise king
is
usually the side of promotes first is
almost always is in
is has the initiative but here it's
reversed yeah yeah
uh-huh so that doesn't seem possible and
maybe bishop g2 we can check
the electric bishop g2 but probably it's
the same
place it's the same story yeah
yeah just uh with the g4 pawn but that
doesn't change anything
wow so maybe black loses in this line
yeah so probably black has nothing
better to do
rather rudder has nothing better to do
than just to
repeat and accept the draw yeah but if
if
errata goes bishop let's say bishop b5
yeah white can go bishop d3 the bottom
game
is is just a draw or actually
right so he has to go back yeah that
makes a lot of sense
that was close though i mean it looked
like a dead draw at first but he created
some chances
but okay i think also
i missed quite a i
i was following the games and i missed a
bit
but it seems that
now and now it's no chance yeah yep
looks like reddick is thinking but it
appears to be a draw and maybe we can
check out the other game quickly before
i ask for your general impressions and
and let you go so mvl
against anton looks like he's won a
second pawn but now he's pinned
what are your thoughts on this position
my general feeling that it shall not be
enough for a win for white of course
white has two pawns
but some i think that this is
like any harmony i for example how will
they save a bishop okay secondly
rookie five give up one point back but
but okay it's not a or maybe
we blunder something engine says us yeah
maybe he takes takes takes for k4
okay maybe bishop d7 or something
ah yeah that forces the rook onto a dark
square
our bishop d3 there's ah bishop d3
bishop b5 bishop takes it
was my idea but bishop
oh my god that's crazy it's just e6
wow i mean there's so many crazy
resources in these end games maybe
white can try rook a4 on just on 47
yeah but probably he has to but let's
say
king g5 oh yeah also nasty
maybe i have a threat i have an idea if
i can play let's say
rook h8 rook h1 after king g5 d5
and try to create threats
yeah it's looks very unpleasant could be
made in certain positions
but generally i have a feeling the worst
case scenario
black will get a pawn back and probably
it will be
enough for for a draw of course white uh
problem gets uh
they have to try this two points up here
but
uh objectively and they
are and he has much more time
yeah maxine yeah 18 minutes for david
yeah for david maybe what move is it
40 so for 13 more moves before before 15
minutes are added
not that simple not that simple for
black but
i do believe that it's closer to a draws
and joy with
but of course it's not that one-sided
yeah
no that that makes a lot of sense well
we'll keep an eye on this game but
before
uh we will let you go and enjoy the
games maybe
i could have your general impressions on
the tournament do you have a
predicted winner and maybe also your
thoughts on uh farouja i know everybody
is always very interested in
uh what you know the legends think of
ali reza and his chances to continue his
success no i think it's hard very hard
to predict in one tournament but of
course ali reza
has enormous potential he shows it
and he is progressing a
only thing which
maybe i'm too you know old and
conservative
but i think that he is playing too much
bullet
well i'm enabling that sorry i'm
enabling that behavior because a lot of
it is against me
yes i know i know i know because it's a
lot of fun and it's a good
big temptation but you know
to play classical and they develop
different qualities i
will say it's bad but for each time
control
different qualities are required
and the trick definitely develops you
know ability to spot things immediately
but probably an ability to go very deep
it's kind of diminishes i really don't
know maybe he plays
just with you and uh okay he
hopefully works a lot on chess we can
see from his game that he is
progressing
constantly progressing right no
definitely
but of course he is
but it's not i think makes no point to
predict how he'll do in this tournament
the next tournament
right he's really on on the way
up and they generally
my feelings that nowadays it's very hard
to judge because
okay it's the first day maybe second
tournament after
stavanger for a long period but when
hopefully
a chess life will restore
to uh maybe not too full but
we'll have more grounds to judge
how young players made the biggest
progress in this lockdown time
right it's testing the work effect well
uh
and the last thing was uh we just were
informed of the death
uh tragically of grand master lubamir
kavalak
who played many times in wacon z i'm
sure you've you've uh
crossed paths with lubimir do you have
any experiences with him that you might
want to share upon
his steps what happened with him
uh i think that what we got what the
information we got was this uh
short but severe illness that's what's
written in the article
i see i say yeah because it's really sad
day
i uh less than a year ago
we bought my guest of the praxis
festival
and we had a chat with him and
very it was always a big pleasure to
talk with him
a person with a good sense of humor with
a good
knowledge of chairs and the big
patient to chest and i remember that
in the during this prague johanna mafek
is a great study composer by showing us
his studies in the lubomir
okay was his mind was very sharp he was
spotting
and ideas very quickly so it's really
sad
news i discussed it already with some
friends today
it's really sad day because uh
okay he was a great chess player
his legacy is a big a lot of great games
but also a very charming and
friendly person
those are some very touching memories
and definitely thoughts and prayers to
lumiere's family
but um grandmaster boris gelfand
absolute legend world champion contender
such an honor to have you in the studio
thank you so much boris for sharing your
thoughts and your insights on on the
games thank you daniel and good luck to
you and good luck to
the tournament i hope it will produce
some
great games so all chess fans will
enjoy like yesterday games between
karwana and duda was really amazing
i analyzed briefly but i intend to do it
in force coming days
in more depths it's really fascinating
indeed well thank you boris and have a
great rest of the day enjoy the games
and and thanks again
thank you danielle and bye bye
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the final
stage of this round four here
in vicanzie but what a pleasure
it was to have the legendary boris
elephant with us
indeed boris he's one of my favorite
personalities in chess he's so
i mean he is legend is the only word i
think
even remotely appropriate to describe
someone like that both in terms of his
chess acumen
and ability the memories that he has the
stories and of course his humility
an incredible class he is one of the
absolute best chess personalities i
think we can all
agree on that that was awesome
incredible and so nice of him
to jump on the call dania let's go back
to the games
is mvl maybe making a little progress
here
yeah i mean mbl found i think this idea
with with d5
and we had consider i think boris
actually proposed this
and it certainly is scary i mean white
has to have nerves of steel to go for
something
because he's he's lining up all of his
rooks
on the eighth all of his rooks and his
bishop all of his pieces on the a file
and he's kind of leaving his king
for the time being to the wolves and
davidson trying to exploit that
centralizing his own king but let's not
forget
white is up uh two puns and uh
speaking of nerves of steel mbl has them
and i think we should find out a little
bit more about the beast
from leon we have his portrait ready for
consumption
it's my first time in vacancy i've
played
in the b section in 2007
and then in the a section as a masters
in 2011 and 2015. so it's been quite
quite a while since since i've been here
what can be played what should be played
i mean there's
a lot of things i can do there's a lot
of openings i've been
playing in the past few months so you
will see
other tournaments and tournaments and
false which
openings i choose to play as a chess
player i
started to understand that i needed to
be fitter
it has paid off already in terms of
fitness but of course there's still
a lot of work to do i think you know
being fit
physically also means you're going to be
fit uh
mentally i mean unless some personal
stuff is happening
most games i'm not very competitive if
not for chess
but i'm only competitive whenever i have
a feeling i can
i can win or i can be on top other than
that i don't really
care about the competition as much and
try more to
enjoy of course over the world it's all
about
winning and you know trying to achieve
my goals
many great competitors who won the event
and i would very much like to be one of
them
[Music]
mvl who hadn't been here in vicanza
since 2015 but it's certainly great
great to have him back as we see him
yawning away there
i mean it's a it's a ruling it's a
grueling tournament
and i'm sure everyone is looking forward
to the
the first dress day tomorrow indeed
indeed indeed and uh
you know exhaustion is hard to hide and
uh you know mvl and
together with duda and others speaking
about the importance of fitness and in
light of how grueling these games are
that is absolutely no surprise the kind
of mental fortitude required
to main maintain a high level
throughout hours and hours and hours of
this uh is is
unthinkable and of course mental
fortitude cannot be achieved
without physical fitness that connection
has been well established so
mvl trying to push a small advantage
here against david
and uh wow just uh such a grueling game
and
uh we'll see if he's able to manufacture
any chances here yeah actually well here
interestingly enough if we look at the
clock situations
david anton could find himself in
another um
[Music]
in another time pressure situation
because he only has 11
minutes for the remaining 12 moves they
are currently on move 48
so move 60 is the final time control
where they get an extra
final 15 minutes and it's actually not
so easy here still
a lot of things to be considered oh
absolutely and uh
boris uh in the end mentioned that
white's king is is in some danger we
talked about this before we
looked at portrait uh you know don't
laugh but
he needs to be careful because if you
fall in love with the extra pawns and
you maybe go back to c4 you try to
protect everything
already white can get mated very easily
here bishop before check
it's checkmate f3 rook b2 king g through
rook g1 and you're just gonna get ladder
mated so
i'm not saying mbl is going to do that
but you have to be on your heels and he
goes d6 i think that's a great move
now he jettisons his pawn and after king
takes d6
the reason he does this is to provide
more mobility to his rooks and also to
expose the king a little bit black's
king
was hiding behind that pawn one thing to
consider is the move bishop d3 in this
position
uh and that doesn't blunder the bishop
of course white reclaims the bishop with
rook d4 and rook takes d3
i would say in a position like this with
four rooks on the board white actually
has pretty decent winning chances i
don't know if he specifically
wants to play bishop d3 i guess we're
about to find out but this does look
like a very sensible mode
yeah bishop d3 has just appeared it has
been played yeah
yeah that's a great great idea by mbl uh
to
minimize the risk now he's of course in
no more danger of getting attracted
uh and david anton it really seems like
at some point he was
he was comfortably in in the driver's
seat and uh
it's just it would be heartbreaking for
him to lose another one of these
very narrow end games i think his
drawing chances still outweigh
mdl's winning chances but this is
beginning to look a little bit grimtiona
yeah i mean he did such a brilliant job
against magnus carlsen the other day but
he's gonna have to produce a similar
a similar defensive effort effort
here today to to hold this game in the
balance
indeed and just to recap what happens in
the event of this end game well
it's not hard to get a read on the
situation white just has an extra apon
and the g pawn is also weak so why does
all of these threats you know rook g3
rook a6 rook g5
and if fight wins a second pawn then the
situation gets really dark for mbl the
king on c6 is sort of caught in the
crossfire
of the rook that doesn't help at all the
king on g2 meanwhile is really safe uh
that pawn on f2 is sheltering the king
from any checks along the second ring
which makes black's defensive task even
harder so
i don't know this looks very nasty for
black indeed
dania i just saw a really nice comment
in the in the twitch uh
chat by pittiglife saying these two
hosts make me want to learn and play
chess
started yesterday and loving it it's
never too late
indeed it's never too late to learn how
to flinch the play charts
and enjoy enjoy the game especially if
you're new to it i know
it's quite an advanced level here but
it's so great so great
to have you all with us and indeed never
too late
indeed thank you for that comment that's
very sweet and as david anton
does capture the bishop on dvd we will
see on the board this end game it might
be worth actually going to e6 it
occurred to me in order to
lend uh as much support as you can to
that on g6
or by the same token kingdom seven also
seems possible
we will see what decision david makes as
he's got yeah he's got ten minutes for
about nine moves this isn't the most
complicated position
but he has to find a defensive
construction that's robust and one
uh final thing that i'll propose before
maybe we can switch to the other game
is putting the rook on the sixth rank
and giving the spawn
full support of one of the rooks keeping
the other rook active
and potentially putting that other rook
behind the pass pawn so
you know apportioning the labor here is
very important between the rooks
in order to avoid any of these um
nasty things from coming to fruition we
will see how david
defends this he goes thing he says
should we go
check in with the bishop ending
alexander donchenko
and radic voitersheik
yeah so we're going to see a draw here
and with boris we were calculating the
fascinating ramifications of the move
bishop f1 and we concluded that
this only looks for trouble after bishop
takes h3 c4
um white actually wins the game and
there's this amazing line i can repeat
this line
after bishop g2 or let's say bishop
takes g4 white
plays the move bishop e2 now if black
takes then the king is able to stop
black spawns but black is not able to
stop white spawns so black must refrain
from the trade
and then pave the way for his pawn so
you get upon race
actually first you play bishop d3 that's
the key you stop the bishop
from capturing on e4 you get a pawn race
and it seems like black remotes first
but no white remote second doesn't
matter
black has no checks and his king is
absolute toast
white's queen and bishop is going to eat
that black king alive so
roddick very prudently deciding not to
go for this line
instead he sort of plays king king a3
and we are going to see here
a repetition of moves i think we're
going to see bishop d3 bishop a2
and uh this game is going to conclude in
a draw any second alexander of course
despite having the extra pawn
cannot make any progress due to the
immense activity of
black species and he does play bishop d3
this game will end in repetition
very shortly yeah let's maybe just stick
around with the camera
for a second alexander has just played
bishop d3 i think
we might just see a draw right right
here
bishop a2 and it looks like the players
are repeating they are and there should
be five by alexander
we will see a stoppage of the box i'm
not going to say a handshake this time
there will be no handshake but a
stoppage of the clocks
and a signing of the peace treaty will
occur
in just one moment and here comes a
three-time repetition
roddick recording is move and calling
over the arbiter
and this one is in the books as well
another draw and this only leaves fiona
mvl against davidsonas maxine trying to
be the only one
who can strike with a victory before the
wrestling
what do you think what are the odds that
uh maxime is going to win his game
not very high i mean the reality is his
chances are by the way sorry daniel just
can you see the the mouth can we go back
to that camera
i love alexander's donchenko's
mask it's not really a face mask it's
like a bandana but he always looks like
i don't know is it like a cowboy i don't
know it's
it's just i find it so funny and i love
that the players are bringing different
different styles of face masks to the
tournament absolutely
and i think before we transition back to
mbl's game do we have
another tweet to show yeah so i saw i
saw a tweet during one of our breaks and
thanks for getting in touch a tweet from
jens
peterson saying could i explain how the
players handled their food situation
this year
uh since the players and staff are in a
covet-free bubble here at tata steel
does that mean that we all eat at the
hotel or does the bubble include
our favorite restaurants and for the
staff too so
indeed this year is a very special
year in that we're in the middle of a
pandemic
and in it does indeed mean that all of
us
the staff and the players we all eat at
the at the hotel so the hotel does the
kitchen is open
but the restaurants some of our favorite
restaurants here in vaikansei
everyone who has been in vikenzie knows
the famous italian restaurant tarantala
you've if you've been here you will have
seen all the best players in the world
at tarantella from magnus carlson to
vishyana everyone has been there dania i
think you have been there
as well uh they are all thankfully open
for
takeaway so we can still we can still
get our favorite pizza
at klein switzerland for those who have
been here also open for take away as a
zona vanc
so they're open for take away but
unfortunately
we have to eat the food in the room
yeah and that's the situation
very interesting sona monk has the best
french onion soup for some reason i
still remember it i lost that i miss
wake up
yup and pizzeria of course that pizza is
absolute killer
man so much soccer pizza i'm going to
i'm going to make a beeline
for something hearty right after the
commentary ends
i'm starving so all this soccer food
let's hope mbl uh well i was gonna say
hopefully they hurry up but i think the
players i
know rosham via if he can get to win
he's gonna sit here
for another two hours if he hasn't yeah
let's go back to his game no this this
one this game is gonna is
he's going to take up every second of
those 40 minutes trying to
uh trying to win this position now i
will say that his chances are quite slim
and and the reason is uh the reason is
that
i just don't see how white white's going
to make progress because the moment he
starts pushing his pawn black can
get his rook to a1 and this other rook
just as we discussed
david has positioned it such that it
defends the pawn on g6
i just don't see any targets here
there's attempts he can torture him for
forever um
but um i just don't really see it
happening to be honest
let's see we have some super cameras
here in the playing hall let's see if we
can get
a close-up of the board and
inspect the action okay
so we're going in inch by inch and here
we are there we go zooming in
and we're zooming in even more uh-oh
and are we zooming in even more
nice nice nice
those cameras i mean that's
impressive i know look at that that is
just you don't get that every day that's
really cool
yeah that is high that's just high-tech
stuff right there
i i hope dgt uh paid paid as well for
this uh product placement
wow look at like is that it wow that is
working
incredible and zooming back out no i'm
laughing but it's actually really cool
yeah you can see the dust particles on
the board that is
the kind of definition and the zoom
quality in these cameras
it's incredible technology is uh
what can i say technology is impressive
it really is it really is as david
ponders where to put
that king of his which is in check and
uh we
think that he will put it on g7 riveting
end game here
between the field and david
okay let's see let's see in the chat
what do people think
how is this game going
to end let us know your thoughts i'll
ask you as well dania
in terms of percentage what are the
chances uh
this is going to end in a draw and what
are the chances amviel is going to
squeeze out the win
i'm going to give it like 80 chance of a
draw especially because when move 60
right he's gonna get 15 more minutes
which is not
actually that much time but it
the thing is like he doesn't have to
make that many decisions it's not like
one of those positions where nbl has
like five different tries and you know
you try this that and the other thing
uh at some point nbl is going to have to
start pushing his pawn david's own as i
explained we'll put his work behind it
and uh you'll get a situation like this
and maybe if mbo can try to push this
bomb through to a6 somehow a7 you can
try to use checks against black's king
that's where the 20 comes from but david
given his defense against magnus i do
have confidence in his ability
to save this position and to make that
drug
and looking at the chat i think they are
even
giving it more than an eighty percent i
barely saw any mvl
win uh votes in there so looks like we
are all
all expecting a draw meaning everyone is
gonna go
into the restaurant nobody is going to
go into the rest day feeling
entirely miserable indeed and that would
be
you know all draws but so many combative
games today and we
we've had our fun that's for sure you
know so and that's understandable uh the
players will eat
in peace they will not be will not be
angry at all
take a deep breath everyone's on the
board and um
yeah as we see we need to step away to
g7 with this game
yeah and mvl okay so let's
see how can we i guess the only winning
plan is to mobilize the
the a pawn yeah but there's nothing
there's really nothing
zero i mean because after a4 i wouldn't
say he will offer a draw i would do
something like this put the rook on f4
just try to stop black from winning the
pawn with before
but uh david what he can do is he can go
rook a2 he can also tie himself to this
pawn
and the biggest issue is you know let's
say that white goes rook a7 and a5
blackjack rook b5 and after a6 or b6
it's already a drop because the pawn is
lost there's just nothing
to be done here at all and uh it's only
a matter of
finding the right placements for um
for his rooks and as he ponders that i
believe that we have an interview with
the one and only anish giri
correct that is correct
[Music]
anish without really knowing what was
going on
i told some reporter uh that you had
sort of to fight for a dog was that
correct
yeah maybe i don't know i um it was a
theoretical variation
i think until very far it was all played
before at least that's what i
thought at least that's what i knew and
um and then i had a choice to keep the
queens on the board because i have
compensation for the
for the pawn and pawn down but i have
two bishops first i was planning to
keep the queens on the board and i was
not sure if my compensation is good
enough to play for more than equality
or not and i was choosing a lot and um
yeah double guessing there but finally i
decided to trade
the queens and then i'm playing just
just for equality i don't think
i was ever in great danger i think the
safety margin is enormous in such
positions
but uh yeah it was an interesting choice
in the before to keep the queens or not
decided to to take the easy route here
okay and now tomorrow is the first rest
day
are you satisfied with your plate so far
yeah the rest day is very welcome
because
my last few tournaments i usually play
around three days long
so this is already today is the fourth
day i'm feeling you know
feeling the heat so yeah rest day is
great uh so far
the place okay um please okay yeah
i honestly i was hoping to get chances
yesterday
um but i really didn't get any i was
actually
only you know on the worst side for the
most part of the game so
didn't really get chances i must say
that a lot is about getting chances in
modern chess
everybody's well prepared it's very hard
and you already got used to the new
conditions
here i can say yeah yeah no it was fine
i was at first a little bit concerned
that you know this would be very empty
and silent and it would feel lonely but
you know once the game starts actually
i'm so focused and have so many problems
to solve that
it doesn't seem to be an issue at all
okay thank you
thank you
[Music]
anishkayi looking forward to the first
rest day as i think we all do i mean
it's a good thing i think without the
three rest days it might
might seem like a lot to people watching
the tournament from afar
like why do these guys why can't we
watch any chess today
why is there yet another yet another
rest day but when you're here
playing uh it's a different story
yeah and hopefully we've transmitted
some of the the reasons behind that i
mean
if there are no rest days the players
would literally collapse from exhaustion
and so would we uh because there's just
so much going on every day and the
players
you might have one game you know don't
they get a chance to have to be
well they do but it's it's just it's not
enough and that extra day of full sleep
fully unplugged that is just absolutely
necessary
uh to keep their energy levels at least
reasonably high
yeah and i'm curious this year what
not much is going to be done on the on
the rest day here in vike well
we're still in a pandemic everything is
closed uh
most players are still still in doing
their quarantine actually
i think the quarantine for most players
will end on the 23rd
so even if we wanted to go somewhere we
wouldn't be allowed um
and yeah mvl
mvl he is probably tired but
even more than the tiredness he wants to
try and see if he can squeeze something
out there was a poll
in the chat and 68 people still believe
that
mvl can win the game
yeah i mean that's interesting because
well one thing to notice here king g3
would threaten checkmate just kind of
funny but davina's
son that has seen that and um that
represents my mental state at the moment
and rook f6 i think is the saving move
here
opening up that f5 square for the king
so you can still give a check that's
your king f5 you can even trade rooks
but if you look at how awkward white
species are he's just gonna end up
losing that pawn
and uh even if he doesn't this is still
a dead draw so
i would be i would put some faith into
david's defensive
capabilities here i probably mexican is
going to end up playing a4
but um after rookie two you know he's
very likely to to lose that pawn time
control is almost at hand
so that he will get those additional 15
minutes to make sure that he can
retain his precision as he tries to
round this
effort off yeah i think here well he
only has three more moves
uh to make i think there shouldn't be
too many problems making this uh
final time control and i also i
i agree with you i think he's already
shown you know like
i think the end game against magnus he
was under a lot more pressure
uh than he is here he did great then and
i don't think we're going to see a
collapse from david anton here
no unless there's some sort of a crazy
blunder and one idea that occurred to me
to go rook to a3
and you're hoping that black goes rook
have six
and tries to trade rooks and then swings
back to d3 and the rook is lost king f5
rook f3
but this is all all pipe dreams david
will not plunder such a thing he can
just go
i mean maybe rook v5 is inaccurate there
are some
um some issues but i'm sure the david
will solve them
successfully and as he does let us
remind everybody of
the results today well uh they are not
hard to recap are they here
because there's only one type of results
they are not and actually
after that we're probably not gonna
stick around until the end because
there's so much more chess action
tonight title tuesday just started 15
minutes ago
we'll send you guys there in a sec but
yeah the results they have all ended
peacefully
that does not mean the games were
uneventful
far from it especially if you haven't
seen them you're just tuning in now
make sure to check out the game between
arie and tawi and
alireza furuja lots and lots and lots of
fireworks and our prediction is that
this last game between
mvl and david anton is going to end in a
draw
as well then next up we're going to
remind you
of the schedule tomorrow if you tune in
at two o'clock you're not going to find
us because it is
a west day the first of three rest day
dania and myself
we'll be back on the 21st i actually
need to go to my laptop to see what day
that is that is
first day so two days from now is first
day we'll be back
at 2 p.m central european time which is
the local time here
in vikenzi and we'll be with you two
more rounds around
five and round six after that we have a
switch up
in commentary teams round seven you will
have texts of it
and simon williams the ginger gm
and finally the last six rounds of the
event
uh you'll have sopico guramish philly
and mr robert has so
lots more to look forward to and
dania before we end the show let's just
look at the pairings for the round uh
after the rest day absolutely let's uh
see who plays suez the log jam at the
top that
uh that was formed at the end of the
last round it remains at the end of this
round so the pairings are going to
define
a lot here we can see carlson playing
don't you go that's a game that magnus
is definitely going to try to win
fabi same here with sepenko rendelius
that's hilarious um but yeah uh
american grandmaster niels mendelius and
swedish grandma's pregnant for a while
mouthwatering matcha that we will look
forward to as the youngsters take on
each other both in very good form
we will be keeping a close eye on that
game and that will be coming your way
once again not
not tomorrow but the day after tomorrow
absolutely and
we are going to end this show here once
again a big thank you to all of you guys
who watched us
throughout the day tanya thank you and
enjoy enjoy your rest day as well as
all of you guys watching us and i think
we're going to send you over
to the coverage of title tuesday
so lots more chess as i said to look
forward to have a good one thanks for
watching everyone yeah thank you
[Music]
everybody
you